of the United States of America and to
the Republic religious stands one nation
under God indivisible with liberty and
justice for all
I'm representative Michael vozabetic and
as chair of the house science technology
and energy committee
I find that due to the state of
emergency declared by the governor as
the result of the covid-19 pandemic
and in accordance with house rule 67 and
the governor's emergency order number 12
pursuant to executive order 2020-04
this public body is authorized to meet
electronically
this is a full committee work session of
bills referred to the science technology
and energy committee
there will be no executive sessions held
today
please note that there is no physical
location for members of the public to
observe and listen contemporaneously to
this meeting
however in accordance with the emergency
order I am confirming that
all members of the committee and select
legislative staff have the ability to
communicate contemporaneously during
this meeting through the zoom electronic
meeting platforms and the public has
access to contemporaneously listen and
if necessary participate in this meeting
by the zoom platform or by telephone
all necessary access information has
been made available in the house
calendar and through the electronic
calendar on the general court website
the notice for this meeting complies
anyone who has a problem accessing the
271-3600 or email
ledge.state.nh dot u s
in the event that the public is unable
to access this meeting the meeting will
be adjourned and rescheduled
the staff
that is assisting us today is Jennifer
for the Ste committee researcher
please note that all votes that are
taken during this meeting will be done
by a roll call vote
however there is no plan to take any
meetings today to take any votes
let's start the meeting by taking the
roll call for attendance when each
member states their presence please also
State whether there is anyone in the
room with you during this meeting which
is required by the right to know so Mr
okay it just started now so somebody did
something
a representative
here
representative Harrington here
representative Donner
here
representative
president
I'm here in the committee
[Music]
uh present in the committee room
representative Bernardi the iron
committee
president of the committee role
representative closure president
committee
representative white I am here in by
myself
uh I'm here at my home and I'm alone in
representative
man called our office to let us know
that he did not have an internet
connection today and that he was going
to try to connect by telephone
I see One telephone user on the attendee
list but it's not the number that he
indicated he will call in from
um but if representative Mann has called
in by a telephone if you please press
star 9 to indicate that you need to be
joining the committee that would be
helpful
thank you Jen
I'll try again representative man
will be a lot of represented boxing
president alone in my office
representative
yes I'm here I'm at my home and uh my
wife is roaming around the house doing
work
representative McKee
present
representative
I'm here I'm at my office today by
myself
I'm here and alone representative
here and alone
Doug I think she had a medical procedure
today she told me uh when we met at the
house so I don't think she's going to be
available I'll try to represent man
again
she spoke to me
representative chairman Bose
I'm here in the committee room okay 19
St thank you Mr Clerk
good morning everybody Welcome to a full
committee work session of the science
technology and energy committee I
apologize to any members of the General
Public
who read in last week's calendar that we
were going to be having public hearings
this morning
all the bills listed in the calendar
have already had a public hearing
and it was an error that led to the uh
misrepresentation that today's event
would be of public hearing
the calendar that was published last
night corrected that error to indicate
that today would be a full committee
work session on seven different bills
two of which are going to be the subject
of our discussion here this morning
so let me explain a little bit about
what's going to happen on Monday we're
going to exec beat bills originally we
were going to exec seven bills but we
discovered one bill that somehow we
forgot to exec earlier we thought we had
accepted but we hadn't couldn't find any
record that we had
so we had to add that to the list so
we're going to exec eight bills on
Monday
now six of those bills will be retained
so
we really don't need to have any
discussion of those six bills today
unless the committee absolutely wants to
do that
and if you do then we will but there's
no real need to discuss those six bills
and
the only two bills that we really need
the first bill that we will
end it HB 106.
we will discuss try to discuss those two
bills this morning now at noon time
we have a hard break at noon time
because we have committee members that
have obligations between noon and one
and then at one o'clock we will
reconvene and the Department of
Environmental Services will give us a
presentation
that probably will last anywhere from an
hour to possibly even as long as two
hours
and of course the week of that
presentation will depend on how many
questions
there are for the Des Representatives
who make the presentation
presentation is over if anyone feels
compelled to have further work safe work
session discussions
on any of the bills that we'll be
executing on Monday we can do that
if there is no
urgent requirement by the majority of
those in attendance to have further work
session discussions then we will end our
work for today and we'll see you all
back here on Monday
I assume we have a couple of questions
before we start so first the chair
recognizes representative oxenham for a
question
thank you very much Mr chair for taking
my question
I don't understand why you would suggest
that we not discuss the bills that are
listed on our agenda today it's our
opportunity to learn what they're about
to discuss them to see where we have
commonalities to see where we might be
able to bridge disagreements uh I I
thought you know we're now facing
perhaps a month with no sessions the
Breakneck speed that we had to move
through our bills is off of the back of
our necks we can take our time and be
thoughtful and do the work we were sent
here to do I would ask you to reconsider
okay thank you for your question uh
representative Samson just recognized
for a question yes thank you Mr chairman
uh it's not a question it's um basically
uh just amplifies what uh represent
oxenham just said
um and I I was the one who added that a
while back had asked that we have work
sessions so we can discuss these bills
among ourselves so even if we are not
we're not going to end up acting on them
but retaining them I think there's a lot
of value to be gained with having
members be able to kind of exchange
ideas about why why they think this bill
or that bill is good or not good I think
there's a lot of learning experience
that can be gained especially since we
have many new members so um
you know I don't think you can I don't
think you should restrict any kind of
discussion because it's going to be
retained
so that's just what I'd like to make a
comment about
okay thank you representative it's not
my intention to restrict comment just
point out that when you retain a bill
what happens is you basically start the
process all over again
and uh since we will be doing that with
with these six bills we will have plenty
of time
during the remainder of the
the year between now and July 1st and
then once again starting up in around
the end of August until around the first
of November there were possibly be the
first of December we have lengthy
discussions about each of these bills we
might even want to do a work session on
just one bill rather than
work session on five or six news so that
was my reasoning for doing this but if
we have a majority vote of the committee
to continue having discussions at the
work session today then we will do that
um my question is a little more
fundamental which is I was surprised to
hear that we're retaining a bunch of
bills without having discussed their
status so I'm just wondering where the
decision to retain all our work before
we've even had a chance to vote as a
committee on it has come from
yes thank you for the question
basically that requirement came from
house leadership it turns out that we're
going to have a compressed schedule for
the rest of our session
the speaker has extended the deadline
for the house to deal with its bills
until the crossover date which is April
8th
and it appears now that we're going to
have a three-day session in the first
week of April to deal with all the bills
that we have to deal with and there's
something like 360 of them
and so the speaker has asked us to
retain as many bills as possible
to reduce
the workload that we're all going to
have to face in the first week of April
we're going to have three concurrent
house sessions
it's not known yet whether it'll be
Tuesday Wednesday Thursday or Wednesday
Thursday Friday
but we'll have three consecutive days of
house sessions
presumably long days
but we'll have only those days to get
through our work
actually the rest of the house calendar
for this year
so that is the reason for the retain
request on all these bills and
because it was requested by leadership
that's what we will do
I just have one follow-up question if
there are bills that actually might
qualify for itl versus retained though
are maybe in the work session today we
could discuss
that potential because then it would be
also less work on the calendar for the
remainder of the year if the bill really
doesn't have legs in terms of anything
that it's going to do to benefit New
Hampshire there might be some bills in
there that we don't want to retain just
for the fact that we might not want to
uh thank you for that question uh that's
a good point and if we can come to a 21
nothing consensus that a bill should be
you and I will go forward with that
communication
basically what the speaker wants to
avoid is lengthy debates uh we go to our
session the first week of April so any
bill that uh in my judgment could lead
to a lengthy debate I think we should
just put off because I don't think we're
going to be able to accommodate that in
our session in early April so last
weekend coming to a consensus that a
bill should be itl and all of us agree
just write representative oxenham you
have another question
yes I do and it pertains to HB 513 the
Broadband bill that is is now on our our
discussion list
it's a really simple thing which just
tries to get people together to try to
get a Meeting of Minds on an issue that
is at the top of everybody's constituent
list everybody is is saying we need
Broadband in New Hampshire if if we were
to have some action other than just
putting it on the Shelf I think we might
be able to get those leaders from the
community and the companies together to
start working on this because it it is a
matter of some urgency for our
constituents
okay thank you for that comment
s thank you for listening for your
comments I think we should begin today
and the first item on our agenda
is
for HP 315. and I'm pleased to report
this morning
that we have reached an agreement on an
amendment
that for checks the consumer interests
of electricity customers throughout the
state of New Hampshire
without in any way impeding or
interfering with the innovation
some communities want to
develop through the use of community
aggregation Community power plants the
amendment that we're going to be
offering to you today and I don't yet
have the exact amendment number because
OLS hasn't delivered it yet
but I sent you all the text that will be
in the amendment when it finally arrives
earlier today it's in your legislative
email
inbox
the text of this amendment
will serve the interests both both of
the electricity customers across the
state and the communities that want to
do community aggregation Community power
and we're going to go through this
amendment line by line and explain
the agreement that we all have
come up with
and I want to thank all the parties who
worked hard to make this agreement
possible
The Honorable Clifton below who I'm
going to call on in a few minutes to
explain this amendment
members of aggregation companies who
participated in our talks members of all
four of the utilities who participate in
our talks members of the clean energy uh
folks in New Hampshire who participate
in our participated in our talks all of
these folks agreed that this amendment
does what we need it to do to allow
Innovation while protecting existing
customers
so it's it's a truly bipartisan
Amendment it's a truly bipartisan effort
to move
Community aggregation and Community
power forward for the State of New
Hampshire and as we go through it here
in just a few minutes I think you'll
you'll discover that we've put together
something that will
serve the interests of everybody
whose interested in the subject
so without further Ado what I would like
to do now is to
introduce the honorable Clifton below
with whom we worked extremely closely to
put this together
Clifton did all the note-taking he
actually did the word smithing on the
amendment and he knows it intimately and
there is no person better than I can
think of to explain the details of the
amendment
he knows this subject inside and out and
he will explain to us just exactly why
this is a good Amendment for the State
of New Hampshire so Mr below please take
it away
um thank you Mr chairman I want to thank
you for your leadership in facilitating
um this process
um and being willing to put in the time
and uh and also Matthew fossum from
eversource who brought the whole
um eversource Team to bear on working
this in a very tight time frame and
working through the issues
um uh folks from eversource as as well
as other stakeholders that uh
participated in the process
um also contributed important text that
helped Bridge the differences between
the parties
um and as the chairman mentioned um all
four utilities were involved in this as
well as
um folks from Freedom energy Logistics
standard power green a good energy
Henry Herndon uh on behalf of the
community power Coalition you know what
also assisted uh but to get to it um the
the amendment I think is a um I I'm
hoping I'm looking at pretty much the
same document with the same line numbers
that that you may have
um it is a complete re replacement of
the bill so by looking at the amendment
you can really see the essentially the
whole build text
um section one of the bill at the first
page is the same as the bill is
introduced
um section two of the bill is also the
same as the bill as introduced there
were really no issues there
um section three the municipal and
County authorities
um preserves the original set of seven
authorities listed here does qualify
some of them uh in a manner that um you
know better uh protects perhaps the
interest of the distribution utilities
um it does qualified meter reading with
the phrase with commission approval for
meters under controlled by the electric
distribution utilities or used for load
settlement
um and on customer service it clarifies
that that is for aggregation provided
Services
um and not obviously Utility Services
section four of the bill on Municipal
aggregators authorized and and I I don't
know if um Matthew fossum attorney
fossums um has been able to speak as
well but but I would invite him with the
Chairman's permission to jump in on any
of these points and elaborate uh but
section four of the bill is as
introduced
um it was an important clarification for
eversource uh they did not want the
language in this section to be
potentially used uh by Community
aggregations to argue that they had a
basis for being able to take over the
utility Consolidated billing functions
this this does allow
um aggregations to potentially
consolidate their aggregation bill with
other Municipal services such as Water
and Sewer Service uh but but not
um utility provided services so
um
that that was a very important issue for
for eversourcing the other utilities
um
I just received the email from the
office of legislative Services the
amendment has been completed this number
is
2021-0640h and I have just forwarded
the amendment
to
euclip and to the house
Ste committee to Jennifer Ford and to
Carrie Morris
Jennifer if you could produce copies and
bring them to
201 we'd appreciate that so everybody
else checked your legislative email and
you should find a copy of the amendment
as produced by so the one I'm reading
now is that the dentist
what you're reading now is a Word
document that we sent to OLS okay and
what you will receive what you will see
in your inbox is the actual Amendment as
produced by OLS I cannot
I cannot say with certainty that the
words will be exactly the same because
OLS may have changed them but
um they should be pretty simple
sorry to interrupt Cliff go ahead
problem I do now have that and I'm
sending it along to eversource folks as
well
um and so far it does look like it
matches
um and the in the page and line numbers
aren't that far off either so section
five of the bill that starts near the
top of the second page
um is some important cleanup it it
partially reflects the bill is
introduced there was some language
about
um aggregator aggregators that you know
defined her term in this statute
referring to Municipal County
aggregations
uh it puts in some of the the language
that struck out here is language that's
original to the statute going back uh 25
years and it was before there was real
Clarity on what the role of these
entities would be vis-a-vis
um traditional Public Utilities so the
first sentence here that an aggregator
operating under under this chapter shall
not be considered a public utility under
RSA 362 colon 2. that's basically that
is
identical to language that was
um subsequently put in the statute about
competitive suppliers and Commercial
aggregators and Brokers uh It also says
elsewhere in the statute that they shall
not be considered public utility under
that RSA that that's the RSA that um
defines what our Public Utilities for
the purpose of sort of plenary oversight
uh you know overall regulation by the
Public Utilities Commission and um the
second part of that phrase was added a
couple years ago at the request of a
member of um Municipal and County
government and they shall not be
considered a municipal Municipal utility
under RSA 38 which is a statute that
authorizes a municipal
um utilities that would be owned both
electric distribution and uh and provide
power supply and we've got five or six
of those on a small scale level that
date back many uh into the early part of
the last century really
um but in any case
um it preserves the language that is in
the existing statute about giving
aggregations
um uh
an option purely an option to
participate with ISO New England
wholesale energy Market as a load
serving entity for the purpose of
procuring and selling integer capacity
on behalf of their customers
um and and that that was something we
were concerned about
um the original bill would have struck
that language that keeps that option
open it's probably not one that many
will use
um early on uh but it but it may be an
option uh that a few of us want to
consider you know particularly perhaps
for opt-in
um options that that customers might
have
um
regulation of aggregators
um there is there was a section
um there was a rewrite of this whole
whole
um 53 e colon 4 and the bill is
introduced
um this language uh focuses this to
um one particular part of the statute so
the the other sections remain the same
um and this is the one concerning the
option of obtaining
um an aggregate aggregator possibly
upgrading uh the meters to provide
interval metering for load settlement
purposes or or other services
um it's an option that's available today
to large cni customers it's it's not
very available to small customers again
we we've the city of Lebanon and a few
others felt this was important uh to be
able to offer potential value-added
Services probably on a small Scale Pilot
basis initially but to
um
a limited number of customers and so
this was a great concern to eversource
um and so some language that um they
suggested was added that that everybody
found agreeable and that is the language
on um line 17
of um the new PDF the official Amendment
uh which is also line 14 of the word
document uh seeing such metering shall
only be implemented subject to uh
commission commission finding it is in
the public good assuring that meter is
used for distribution tariff
implementation remain under the control
the majority ownership of the electric
distribution utility and otherwise
approving the terms and conditions for
such Arrangements including any data
sharing that might be appropriate
um that I paraphrased there
um
would you like me to pause and see if
there's any questions as we go through
this of myself for you or Matthew
yes that would be useful and in fact
representative Harrington has a question
and is recognized thank you Mr chairman
and uh thank you Mr below for uh doing
all this work on this uh my question was
on we were just talking about uh the
metering uh looking at this it talks
about the um
aggregation could Supply its own Revenue
grade electric meter which would be in
addition to the utility provided meter
is what do you envision happening if
there's two different readings there so
there's the someone decides that they're
going to have their own meter for the
purposes of electric energy but of
course the utility is going to keep one
for the purposes of charging for
transmission and distribution charges so
let's say they don't read the same uh
that would be my first question what
happens then and second when you say its
own Revenue grade electric meter would
that media also be subject to the same
calibration and other requirements that
the that the utilities meter would you
know is like a couple of pages anyways
of requirements for Revenue grade meters
that the puc imposes on the utilities
yes I um I can't imagine a situation
where the POC or the utilities uh would
would approve this without the meters
meeting the same standards uh for
Revenue grade metering uh that are that
are well established uh standards
um
the I think the the difference would be
that I mean if there's already an
interval meter that can measure hourly
intervals uh which is sort of the key
unit of time
um uh for lead settlement purposes uh
that that um
I think the only situation with that
would occur is if for some reason
the utility kept their meter which was
not an interval meter that that was read
say monthly and you have a monthly read
versus uh the secondary meter which was
providing um hourly or more granular
data
um so if there was a discrepancy you
know once you accounted for perhaps a
little deviation of the time stamp
because sometimes the monthly red ones
don't
I don't know if they have a precise time
stamp or not interval meters have to
have a a time stamp
um you know I think that that would be a
cost for investigation and look at one
one or one of these two Revenue grade
meters is not um meeting the standard I
mean there there is a slight plus or
minus that's that's allowed for metering
um
so you know a secondary Revenue degree
metering sort of a last resort although
I will say that these are being put in
now uh by demand response providers who
are participating in a particular ISO
New England program that requires
five-minute interval data with real-time
Telemetry to ISO New England so if they
call upon these resources to do a quick
response ISO New England can see that
they've actually responded because the
compensation is actually based on on
what they're doing in at the five minute
interval
um and so that would be a type of
secondary Revenue grade metering that
that is already being installed pursuant
to ice on New England uh procedures and
if such a meter was installed we
actually have a proposal for that right
now with the city with our Wastewater
and water treatment plants the social
media was installed uh then then perhaps
that meter uh would be an example of
such as secondary Revenue grade metering
that could could also be used for load
settlement as I understand it the
distribution utilities
um all the load settlement goes through
them because essentially they have to
allocate their meter reading at the
wholesale interface between the
transmission grid and the distribution
grid they have to allocate that out on a
daily basis to all of the load-serving
entities
for all the customers every retail meter
has to be within what's called a meter
domain of a load serving entity
that that then gets their share and if
there's actually hourly interval data
available on a daily basis and that's
what's used otherwise there's a very
complicated extrapolation
a secondary
secondary settlement that occurs months
later after after you've gotten the
monthly meter reads
Mr chairman
yes follow-up yeah so just to make it by
make it in the short term here uh what
you're saying is by the fact that it's a
revenue grade electric media you're the
bill would imply that that would have to
meet all the requirements of that
through calibration and so forth and as
far as the discrepancies that was my
exact point because the example
eversource doesn't have any uh interval
meters they're all just monthly red so I
guess if there was a difference between
the two then the commission would be the
arbitrator in those if someone wanted to
push the issue
um yes they would be the arbitrator
um I I would think the util the to the
priorities would want to maybe pull both
meters and have them tested to see which
one's wrong okay um one more follow-up
Mr chairman
okay go ahead uh you we were talking
about the capacity I see you added that
in uh earlier in the amendment as well
so would you consider thou the let's
just say that the municipal aggregator
whatever their load is that would be
relieved from the utilities capacities
obligation
and it would be so they would you know
whatever megawatt hours that would have
been of the up to the whether the
utility would have been charged for
through the capacity Market they would
subtract those hours off that would no
longer be part of their obligation they
would just right into the power yes as I
understand it
um every
every meter every customer gets the
capacity tag which is their program
share of the capacity assigned to the
distribution utility as a whole
um so in the proposed rules everyone's
agreed that um the proposed rules would
make quite explicit that any aggregation
of whether
through their themselves as a load
serving Unity or on contract with
competitive supplier has to provide full
load following service
um which includes the capacity
obligation thank you
that representatively is recognized for
I want to sort of gut check what I'm
reading here it sounds to me like the
language here is saying is basically
describing how the metering will work
when we're not uh simply using the
meters as for our ability for the
utilities to
um do the distribution tariff piece
because we're going to have other
generators assisting in the load and so
since it's undefined that's why we're
distinguishing the two but I I unlike uh
representative Harrington I don't really
see an issue with us having increased
ability to have additional data from
meters since meters are more
sophisticated now if the utilities don't
possess that sophistication because
we've been working you and I have both
been working on the the Statewide energy
data platform and we understand that you
know meters are kind of key to to that
the insights that we want to have on our
system so I guess the question is just
is that all this is because when I look
at it I don't see it as exceedingly
complex I think all it's doing is
distinguishing for us in in the statute
that the metering will be under the
commission's authority to determine
whether it's right and Justin
appropriate and that uh competitive
suppliers will have the ability to
install meters that will allow them to
provide additional services in terms of
understanding what is happening
uh with usage and load
sorry
you remember
that's why I tried just a yes answer on
that one
because because I can elaborate almost
anything here but but I'll try to stay
to the point
so if there's no other questions on this
um the next one is section seven of the
bill at line 23 or you know uh 20 in the
word version
um
and this was important
um I think this is kind of what we
thought was intended all along but it
wasn't really spelled out so it's an
important clarification to protect
non-participants uh uh taxpayers
um ratepayers who are not participating
in the aggregation and it's simply it
clarifies that while um you know the
general statement that has been in the
law since um 1996
um actually uh now Senator Bradley
actually drafted this text originally
um says that the customers who are not
uh participating in the aggregation so
not be responsible for
and no entity shall require them to pay
any costs associated with such program
through taxes or otherwise except you
know electric power supply
or Services consumed directly by the
municipality or County and the the law
originally said or incidental cost
um you know except for except for energy
into incidental cost
um
you know what there's a problem here
um uh representative the house this I
don't think this is quite what was
intended and I'm not quite sure how this
slip through
because it says the way it reads and and
I guess maybe I bear some responsibility
for this it reads that
you can't that they can't even be
incidental costs
and I think at line 27 where it says or
it should say except for incidental cost
which may include costs necessary to
comply with the provisions of this
chapter up to the time that the
aggregation starts to produce revenue
from participating customers but shall
not include any capitalized or operating
cost of an aggregation
um with the ore there the last phrase
could actually be read backwards
um the the type of incidental costs that
have been identified that that a
municipality may need to encourage that
there's requirements for public hearings
for instance before the municipal even
decides to have a plan and our our
community at least pays to have those
public hearing notices published in the
paper uh which would be a type of
incidental cost or another example that
we talked about was a community that
needs to have a legal review of a
proposed contract with a broker or
supplier uh before they've even started
the program that that could be an
appropriate incidental cost which would
be allowed to come from from a municipal
budget
um but to get to the point the important
thing that was being added was at line
29 and 30 to make clear it shall not
include any capitalized or operating
cost of an aggregation program
um and those are those are Concepts that
are pretty clearly defined in the
government Accounting Standards Board
and and dra actually has some
requirements that unit disabilities
follow certain accounting standards and
so the point was to make it clear that
you couldn't you couldn't argue that
some costs that should probably be
capitalized or considering an operating
cost of an aggregation program you
couldn't argue that those are incidental
costs uh that might be allowable
um this is representative rosecliffe I
made a note about the
except for when you and I can talk about
that offline about
I'd like to have you verify for me in
your previous versions of the text that
that's what we intended and if we did
I'll go back to OS OLS and have that
um
any questions on that
representative Harrington is recognized
for a question yeah thank you Mr
chairman uh this is just a typo it looks
like on line 26 it says require them to
pay any cost Associated such program
looks like you're missing the word with
so that's another correction any cost
associated with such program
that's that's that would be correct I
think the word with is in the current
statute okay well
maybe we don't have to worry about it
well no but this is a rewrite of it so
it should be it should be correct okay
when we need to add it that should be
that should be picked up pretty easy
continue Cliff okay so section eight of
the bill
um is electric aggregation plan and uh
that that the only change to the current
section of this law here is
um
that it explains that
um a county plan May provide an
aggregation program for all or subset of
municipalities within the county that
request to participate by majority vote
of their respective governing bodies now
this this is actually sort of a new
issue that was in the bill as introduced
or really brought up during
um hearings
um but it it is sort of a a customer or
Community protection uh issue which is
um and it sort of arrives because
Chester County has been looking at this
and their their thinking was hey you
know if a community has already
considered this and rejected it we don't
want to be doing a county aggregation
plan that brings that municipality in if
they don't want to participate so this
sort of turns that around and allows a
county plan uh that could be for all
um or just a subset of their
municipalities but that would be subject
to the request of those municipalities
to participate by a majority vote of the
respective governing bodies you know
people could still individually opt out
and this the whole plan would still go
to the county legislative uh body uh for
approval uh but but this allows County
to not include municipalities that don't
um
hearing no questions on that I'll move
to number nine
um
well I I should just pause there mention
that there were some other things in six
that the original bill was introduced
that would have um uh until that sorry
um that would have
um
eliminated a couple things that
aggregation plans should look at
um you know how net metering would be
handled and how
um
loan income
residential customers who are getting a
discount through the electric base
aggregation program would preserve that
discount
um so those are left in the statute uh
just because I I think people understood
it's important that aggregation plans
address that and and these were
um things that also the puc felt that
that uh aggregation plans should should
go into people should go into it with
eyes wide open so to speak so that they
don't inadvertently uh cause somebody
some harm by putting them into an
aggregation program that doesn't sort of
uh meet their needs or keep their EAP
discount
um moving to section 9 of the bill
um which starts at the bottom of page
two really continues at the top of Page
Three
um this is a whole rewrite of this
section so you're not going to see in
bold italics new text or strikeout of
old text it's complete replacement
so this this was
[Music]
um
started on with the amendment that I
offered at the public hearing but
there's been considerable uh further
modification as a result of of these
negotiations
um
and so let's see the the section once is
pretty much the same which which says
that um you know the government mean
body uh it says may submit the governing
body could decide that they don't want
to submit it so the the plan would die
at the governing body level level but
then uh they would that's if they want
to advance the plan uh they consider
submit it to the legislative body uh
typically town meeting except for towns
that have town councils and city
councils it's often the same body uh and
and County of course we all know what
the legislative body for the county is
it's the it's the rep state
representative delegation
um they can submit it for final uh
adoption
um or any revision that includes an
opt-out aggregation program it has to be
approved by a majority of those present
in voting that's the current law
um section two here of this RSA starting
at line five
um
does
this is a whole new section it is
somewhat modeled or sort of the takeoff
point was something that was in the
original build
um it requires any plan or any revision
of a plan that's going to include an
opt-out default service program to be
submitted to the commission the puc
either before or after being submitted
to the um by the governing body to the
legislative body for approval
huh that was adoption at one point but
got went back to approval oh well
um to determine whether the plan
conforms to the requirements of this
chapter and applicable rules of the
commission
uh
uh commission uh shall approve any plan
submitted to it unless it finds it
doesn't meet the requirements of the
chapter or other applicable rules uh
cause for them to detail in writing
um those those uh problems to the
governing body of the municipality are
kind of concerned
um and it does have a provision that
failure to disapprove a plan submitted
uh within 60 days shall constitute
approval thereof that's similar to what
happens
um in in other uh situations in the
statute
um
in Municipal your county can submit a
revised plan it sort of restarts the
clock on on this review process
um it is also required to be submitted
at this on the same date to the office
of the consumer Advocate and any
electric distribution utility providing
service within the jurisdiction of the
municipality County
and then the consumer Advocate the
utilities and members of the public can
file comments uh within the first 20
days 21 days of the submission
um and then the commission review and
approval uh it doesn't require contested
case doesn't have to be an adjudicated
proceeding but it has to allow time for
the for the submission of those comments
and the consideration of com such
comments by the commission
so that was a mouthful um but I think
everyone agreed that this is a prudent
thing to do
um and it's similar to what the Attorney
General does though with a 30-day time
period and no public comment on a
proposed joint action agreements between
municipalities counties or other
subdivisions and agencies that
um
representative Pimentel you're
recognized uh thank you Mr chairman just
uh if we're doing typos
line 12
oh
this is Matt it says Matt instead of
meat right there's truth on that and
there's two these okay
I got that
representative
I guess that was the only question okay
let's continue
okay
um
Ramen three is is sort of uh built off
of what's in the current statute
although I think there's there's some
significant uh changes
um
let me see
um maybe not this this is pretty much
what's in the current statute if if
you've got an act out up service
if any plan any plan whether it's opt-in
or opt out uh or if you were adopted an
opt-in plane and it's revised to include
an opt-out service then you then
municipality kind of has to mail writ
notification to all retail customers
within the municipal County
oh this this is um
a part of what's what's new
um to enable such male notification
notwithstanding this RSA about about
customer
um
uh data after an aggregation plan is
duly approved
um the distribution utilities or
utilities are going to provide to the
municipality County current list of the
names and mailing addresses of all
electric customers uh so they can do the
required mailing and for customers that
are in utility provided default service
the account numbers and any other
information necessary for successful
enrollment in the aggregation
elsewhere in the statute I think a
provision that's not amended uh
municipalities and counties are subject
to this RSA 363
38 which requires them to keep any
personally identifiable information
confidential but
um the way these this program works in
Massachusetts they do provide to the
municipal aggregation or this or the
supplier that's working with them uh
this kind of data because it's the
burden is on the supplier to do the
enrollments and they have to have the
account number and sometimes there's
something else a
a name code which is not necessarily the
same as the mailing address name
that that has to be that's needed for
successful enrollment and actually some
of this text was suggested by by
eversource
um
so that was helpful
um the next sentence at line 30 is an
existing statute pretty much you have to
describe the program rights and
responsibilities and if and if it's on
an opt-out basis the fixed rate or
charges that apply uh so
um again this is a customer protection
provision that's in the existing statute
that no retail customer uh shall be
included in a program in which the
customer does not know all the rates or
charges the customer may be subject to
at least 30 days in advance of that
application and has the option for a
period of not less than 30 days from the
date of the mailing to opt out of being
enrolled in the program
unless they affirmatively respond to the
notification request and writing to be
included in the program
so I mean there could be a different
kind of program that somebody opts into
uh
um but but um otherwise people have to
know what you know the rate that they're
going to be charged and have time to opt
out of that
representative Harrington you recognized
thank you Mr chairman uh Mr below I'm
looking at that last section the
starting with the no retail Electric
customer on line 32 going to 33.
and goes on to talk about that the
customer does not know all the rates or
the co or the charges the customer may
pay sub it to at least 30 days in
advance of the customer's application
what's the customer's application we're
talking about this is the end user the
the person consuming the electricity
I noticed that in in one of my read
throughs and and I'm the intent there
the meaning that's intended there is
that
um in advance of the application of the
rate to the customer
um
and somewhere along the way it got
turned turned around I think this is
maybe in the current law or maybe
somehow along the way some words got
dropped so so this might be something
that could be clarified the intent is
that for for
um
that they do not know all the rates or
charges the customer may be subject to
at least 30 days in advance of
um
the application of those charges to the
customer
um follow-up Mr chairman
yes go ahead yeah that's what I assumed
it was supposed to mean not the
customer's application but the
application of the rate to the customer
yeah maybe that's something that's going
to be changed because this assumes that
the if you read this you assume the
customer's making in some kind of
application and it's really we're
talking about applying the the new rate
to the customer
right so that's an ongoing obligation of
the aggregation and well
um that the customer always knows you
know what they're going to be charged so
they can always get out of the program
um
so yes I let's um make a note that that
should be turned around
I made it that's what these work
sessions are helpful for having lots of
eyes on this that even though a lot of
eyes have been on it we still sometimes
miss these things
after all you have to remember this was
a an amendment crafted by a
committee that was some as many as 28
people so it can get unruly at times
opposed to the kennel
[Music]
okay I had to moving on to the top of
page four
uh uh the public meeting to answer
questions is has been in the statute all
along
um
Roman five again this sort of reiterates
this ah here here's here's a way and and
maybe this is where this sort of hybrid
came from
um service is proposed to be offered by
or through an aggregation shall be an on
an opt-in basis unless the program
explicitly recates an opt-out
alternative default Energy Service where
the Raider price is known at least 30
days in advance of its application
um and for a period of not less than 30
days from the date of notification the
customer has an opportunity to opt out
of being enrolled in such a program by
return postcard website or such other
additional means as may be provided
um so I think I think this this was in
the statute
um still is uh and and I think the
implication is there you got to provide
a return postcard and a website at least
um
there are some changes here that um were
partially
well I'm not sure it was in the bill is
introduced but it was in a previous uh
proposed amendment by by eversource uh
it clearly puts the obligation on the
aggregator to provide
um uh the enrollment
um
it also provides that
um customers opting out will instead
remain on the utility provided default
service and if you're taking service
from a competitive supplier you're
you're not to be enrolled in the
aggregation program unless that customer
voluntarily opts in
um
Romans 6 is to solve a problem that we
all agreed was a problem and when we
started talking about uh rules and the
informal stakeholder process of the puc
which is how to deal with new customers
after the initial
mailing has been done and
uh this this I think everybody felt
finally works correctly and consistently
with how it's done in Massachusetts so
ever source and Unitil that do this in
Massachusetts don't have to change their
systems or or software to accommodate
this which is to say that um upon
request of an aggregator not but not
more than monthly uh the utilities
they'll make available to each operating
Municipal Aviation or County aggregation
where there's no Municipal aggregation
the names account numbers mailing
address and other information necessary
for successful enrollment in the
aggregation of customers that are new to
or then currently on electric
distribution utility provided default
service
um after they provided that initial list
and they're located within the service
area
um the aggregation so periodically mail
a written notification to such new
customers that have not previously opted
out of the aggregator service and shall
enroll them in the aggregation
consistent with the opt-in or opt-out
requirements that were previously
expressed
um and the the subtlety here just so you
understand in Massachusetts they don't
actually provide a custom list of new
customers they said it's actually just
easier to provide all the customers that
are then say you know six months later
that are then on
utility provided default service and the
burdens on the aggregator to tease out
those that had previously opted out so
they're not bothered with the second
opt-out notice so they're only mailing
to new customers and those new customers
um
uh the Romans 7 at line 26 is is the is
the same as current law uh Roman 8
um does have some additional customer
protection Provisions that were
particularly suggested by Mark Brown uh
that that you know he found were
satisfactory the first sentence is one
that's an existing statute
um about customers uh who are enrolled
in a municipality a municipal County
provided default service meaning the
opt-out uh sort of basic service shall
be free to elect a transfer to utility
provided default service or to a
competitive supplier with adequate
notice in advance in the next meter
regular meter reading
um in the same manner as if they were
unusually provided default service or as
approved by the commission that's that's
in current law the new thing is that no
such customers should be required to pay
an exit fee or charge for such transfer
you know and I I kind of thought the
previous sentence said that but this
makes it very explicit no exit fee you
you there's no cost if you want to go
back
on a regular meter reading cycle there
is additional sentence here that says
customers requesting transfer of Supply
service on a date other than the next
regular meter read
may be charged an ice off cycle meter
reading and billing charge these are
things that are in the distribution
utility tariffs because um if you don't
have the
um interval metering with with
communication
um which actually the co-op and Unitil
do but but but the eversource and
Liberty don't you know they have to send
somebody out to do the special meter
read and then do a special billing and
they have a charge for that in their
tariffs so that could be passed on to
the customer
if they say you know I want to be trans
my next meter reads in three weeks I
want to be transferred um you know
tomorrow then then there could be a
charge
for a couple of questions yeah
that represents it's your record
a question
uh and don't forget to stop I'm not sure
all right can you hear me yes we can
okay okay
the question I had uh I have several but
one of the questions I have is customer
moves into a new neighborhood
somebody you know they tell them you
have to connect the utilities etc etc
and they know they have to do that does
anybody give them that they're uh tell
them that there are options in the
community
um I mean we discussed that yeah that
was sort of in the original
um
but but the the utilities didn't want to
have to have that responsibility
um so they just automatically go into
the utility provided default service
um until uh the uh six months gets gets
the um information and can uh do a
mailing to the to the new customers and
um then they would have the choice uh to
um opt out and stay on the utility
provided default service but the
aggregator for six months wouldn't have
that information is that correct well
they they can request it up to once a
month
um they can which is sort of one thing
but the utilities yeah
they do it one they do it once a month
you don't you know it's like too much of
a bother to do it more frequently than
that
um for for both sides
I just wanted to clarify that because
I think that customers should have the
options municipality should know who's
moving into their municipality that
should be very easy for them to get
counties a little bit more difficult but
through registrations of Deeds they
should know that uh and I wondered if it
was going to be six months but it
shouldn't be okay that's all I needed to
know like you're on video now I don't
think you need to use your phone
uh lee yeah I'm a grown woman my my
okay thank you representative samsich is
yeah thank you Mr chairman uh Mr below I
just a question uh how how is um in the
case that uh representative Kelly Pitts
just mentioned where somebody moves into
a new home uh let's say it's somebody in
Lebanon that moves from one address to
another address even though they were
previously uh customers of the same
utility does that show up as a new
customer or is that just a address
change of a previous customer how does
how would that be handled
um
in the previous section
um at lines uh sort of 14 15 16
if they relocate
um
within the same utility service area and
they're continuing service with a
competitive supplier
um or if you move within the same town
and you're in a municipal aggregation
and you're on the municipal aggregation
um or the same county same thing uh then
then you stay on that service so if I
just move across town I'm on the
municipal aggregation then I would just
stay on the municipal aggregation if if
I move in from another town and I'm on
competitive Supply and that suppliers
also serves in the same jurisdiction
you'd stay on that and that's the case
today
um but if you're new to the town and you
aren't weren't on the aggregation
program uh then then that's where you'd
be
um sort of automatically you put on the
utility provided default service because
because that's the only way their
systems are set up
um and and so they they basically
indicated this this would be a major
problem if they were to try to change it
to confirm with the existing law so
that's why this law change is important
so so you
you know the aggregation still has an
option to pick up those customers on an
opt-out basis
um but
um
but they wouldn't
um you know it's more the burdens on the
aggregation to process the customer so
the utility uh so you know we're not
creating new costs for the utility that
they don't have today okay thank you
thanks Cliff I just want to remind you
it's 1106 and we have a hard stop at 12
o'clock
okay
um
the the final thing at the bottom of
page four was just that if a customer
um requests the aggregator that they
want to go back to utility provided
default service the aggregator shall do
that uh so again the burden's not on the
utility to do that the utilities
sometimes do that because the customer
may just come to them uh but but they
would prefer that the aggregator take
that responsibility for executing it's
often called A Drop That A supplier or
aggregator drops the customer and then
they automatically go back to you to
leave providing default service
um
um you know at the top of page five this
Roman nine
um just says if you
originally had an opt-in program and you
want to do an opt out then you have to
go back through the process previously
described
um
the section uh 10 at line five uh this
starts off the way it was an existing
statute but the new language uh really
starts at the end of line six and um or
really line six all together uh that's
to the extent authorities granted didn't
spies and counties by this chapter
materially affect the interest of the
distribution utilities and their
customers the reasonably balance such
interest with those of the
municipalities and counties for the
public good uh which may also be done
through adjudicative proceedings to the
extent specified or not addressed in
rules so that's sort of a mouthful but
the concept you know the concept of
public good is one that's really well
established in case law for the Public
Utilities Commission it has to do with
balancing interest
um the current sort of laws that the POC
is an Arbiter of the you know they
balance the interest of the utility and
their rate payers this is sort of adding
a third party to the picture which could
impact the utility itself off so this
makes it clear that the commission you
know can address this the rules and the
the rules the draft proposed rules you
know specify certain things that would
get kicked out to an adjudicative
proceeding
um are there might be things that come
up that that nobody thought of to
address in the rules that that would
allow the commission to take that up
through an adjudicated proceeding where
they could settle the issue so it just
it just provides
um sort of additional uh assurance that
the commission has oversight in any way
in which these aggregation might uh
particularly adversely impact the
um The rulemaking Authority was expanded
by you know everybody thought it was
better to make express some of the
things that the rules should include but
not limited to including metering
billing access to customer data for
planning or operation
um
and the other language was stuff that
was in the current statute
um
moving to section 10 which is the final
section of the bill if there's no
questions on this previous one
um this was something that was uh in the
bill is introduced but in in very
um
very short form and expanded upon in you
know the previous suggested
um amendments uh but but after a lot of
this this one took a lot of talking to
work through and get everybody on board
but basically it provides that um
there'll be a purchase of receivables
program and that at minimum it would
apply to
um aggregations either those that are
serving as blood-serving entities or a
competitive electricity supplier serving
um it can include other competitive
suppliers generally uh and to the extent
and for such rate classes as the
commission finds after notice and
hearing that it's for the public good so
it's it's somewhat uh puns the question
of the if this is available to everyone
or not a little bit down the road
um different utilities have different
point of view on this and that's why the
final sentence is here uh such a
determination shall be on a utility
specific basis if proposed and ascended
to by the utility and what we know is
that eversource for instance because
they do this for all suppliers in
Massachusetts and Connecticut uh their
preference is to do this for all
suppliers that use Consolidated billing
that's what this is about which you'll
see in the next section
um that they would like to provide this
to all
um yeah and I know that Liberty I'm not
sure exactly where the co-op is but
Liberty uh doesn't want to do that
um they want to just provide por for
um
Municipal and County aggregations so
what's por
um this final paragraph uh Roman 2 sort
of describes the parameters of it
um it leaves it to the distribution
utility or requires the distribution you
tell you to propose to the commission
for re View and approval APR program in
which detail pays in a timely manner the
amounts due to the supplier from their
customers for electricity Supply less a
discount percentage rate equal to the
utilities actual uncollectible rate
adjusted to recover capitalized and
operating costs specific to the
implementation operation of the purchase
of receivables program including working
capital again a mouthful but what that
means is that there is a cost to setting
up capitalize costs software computer
software changes
the billing software changes uh maybe
business process and there's ongoing
operating costs to do this uh to
implement and operate the POR including
a working capital which which is you
know the utilities and the Utility
Commission you know it's well
established how they figure out you know
a compensation for lead and lags on you
know payments and working capital uh
that's all um as you'll see in the next
sentence or two that's all
um going to be put on the POR program
and not existing rate payers
um so it goes on additionally such
discount rate adjustments show include a
prior to share the cost of ministering
collection efforts such that the
utilities participation in the POR shall
not require the utility or
non-participating consumers to assume
any costs arising from its use so you
know if if a customer goes under you
know walks away they've left a thousand
dollars due that's bad debt you can't
collect it because they've moved out of
state
um and it's not worth the bother or you
might try to collect it
um on behalf and that's that's shared
between the aggregation the distribution
and transmission charges uh then you're
going to prorate the cost of trying to
collect that to
um uh the the the different uh programs
um but you're going to allocate
um well this is actually the next couple
sentences you're going to allocate the
cost attributable to this program uh to
the program including the write-offs
from the portion of the supply so just
to wrap it up such Paretta shares the
cost must include but not be limited to
any increases in the utilities bad debt
write-off attributable to participants
in the plr program as approved by the
commissions so the commission has some
oversight
um the allocation of costs arising from
different rate components and
determination of the uncollectible rate
shall be Equity allocated between such
suppliers utility provided default
service and other utility charges that
are part of Consolidated billing
um as approved by the commission and the
final provision is the discount
percentage rate she'll be subject to
periodic adjustment as approved by the
commission which is how they do it in
other states so if if that rate is under
collecting or over collecting it can be
periodically adjusted so it so it's
essentially reconciled to actual cost
so that was a fast explanation of of por
but um I think everybody uh went away
feeling like this this is the kind of
language that creates the parameter so
there's not cost shifting uh either for
the cost of the program or the bad debt
that might arise from A supplier uh uh
charges to customers that don't don't
pay their bill uh but but
um a lot of suppliers feel that this is
a very important thing for them to enter
the market uh because they're not in it
it's difficult for them to chase
individual residential customers for
just part of the bill
so I'll I'll stop there thank you if
that was a fantastic
explanation of what amounted to what six
or seven or maybe even eight hours of
negotiation discussion uh you did a
terrific job in 45 minutes
explaining the contents of the amendment
I see that representative Thomas has a
question and is recognized oh uh
actually it wasn't intending to put my
hand up on what's it exactly but I was
going to say just like these chair I was
very impressed with this situation line
by line something I've been wanting to
thank you thank you
half of the entire committee
representative samsich is recognized for
a question
yeah thank you Mr chairman and thank you
uh Mr below for the for great at uh
presentation that we we tried hard to
understand uh on the last page there I
think there's a typo here that probably
needs correcting as well on the last
section under billing Arrangements
um at the end of the first first section
paragraph it says such a determination
May shall be
right and representative I was I think I
think that was because the May was
crossed out uh in in track changes and
replaced with shell at Liberty's
um request so I think shell
um was was kind of what was
um
consented to assented to at the end of
Ary
foreign
I see one way over in the corner the
diploger is recognized for a question
thank you Mr chair
um
have a question
yes thank you
um
objectives about using their capacity
our capacity and Supply they had some
plans I was aware of this allow them to
continue with the plants and Community
energy Traditions yes
yep with this amendment
um we we don't see any problems or
barriers to uh doing some of the things
we're starting to plan plan for which
which we hope will prove to be value
added services to our um rate payers
and
is what others thank you for that point
okay are there
comments uh anybody on the committee any
questions it is a long and complex
been
in attendance with all six seven eight
hours I don't remember exactly how many
hours that we spent on this
having watched and listened to every
single minute of that discussion I'm
confident that this amendment does what
everybody wants it to do and
once we get the typos fixed I think this
will be an amendment that we can all be
very happy with uh representative
Harrington is recognized yeah thank you
Mr chairman I just want to say first I
want to thank everybody for all the hard
work and it's a way of background you
know uh the chairman and I put this bill
in it was sort of a placeholder at the
last minute because we knew something
had to be changed but we didn't
necessarily endorse what was put in but
we needed something out there so the
bill was put into play and there's been
a lot awful lot of hard work on this by
a lot of people and
um I had some real serious concerns on
some of the issues and I think they've
been addressed and uh I'll be supporting
the amendment and again thanks for all
the hard work that was done by so many
individuals on this I think it's
something we can do for the people and
let the uh you know the aggregators and
municipalities uh have their goal and if
it doesn't work for them well they can
always come back but let's give them the
opportunity to try
thank you representative samsich is
recognized for a comment yes thank you
Mr chairman uh I too want to extend my
appreciation to the chairman also to
state representative Kelly Pitts who was
working many hours on this as well and
to Mr Bilo obviously so I think it was a
great great effort and I really uh
okay if anybody
if anybody
that's about my point rate I wouldn't
know who to go to for uh a city to an
application but Jackie if you know the
proper authorities to go for it
he's out there in Iraq right now
[Laughter]
okay any further uh representative McGee
is uh recognized for a comment
Mr chairman yeah no it was just a
clarification
ended today those will go back to OLS
when will we have a clean Amendment
well I will try to get them to uh OLS
during our lunch break from 12 to 1.
um
I don't know if I'll succeed and I don't
know if they'll be able to turn anything
around today but I'll get them in as
quickly as possible and they'll turn it
around as quickly as as soon as they can
okay
hopefully we'll have them for Monday so
we can know what we're voting on because
we definitely have to have them for
Monday because we can't adopt an
amendment with us right the correct
Amendment so yes we'll definitely have
it by Monday
seeing that I guess we can uh
move on with this issue to bed and once
again I offer my thanks to everybody for
so I would like to next if it's okay
with the rest of the committee to
discuss uh house bill 106.
I had sent around on Wednesday a
potential Amendment
there are some
it's not a perfect Amendment it may
require some additional adjustments but
to start a conversation about whether or
not we could find enough consensus on
this bill to move it forward this year
if we cannot then we will retain it but
um thought that this might be a starting
point for a discussion and so I'd like
to hear if uh what kinds of thoughts
people have about the amendment it's
and uh I can go through it I I did in
the email that I sent when I sent it out
I indicated what the major changes were
I can go through that again if you would
like
okay I found the original email
so the amendment makes the following
changes
before I go through these maybe I should
recognize some folks who have their
hands up
Representatives Pimentel if it's
recognized for a question or a comment
thank you Mr chairman
I I'm just wondering about the reasoning
behind the geographic limitation on the
bill uh line 19.
on page one you could explain
representative Lang I have with a new
permission to speak and since this was
part of your original bill
I'm sorry I had my microphone off
representative Lang did you hear the
question by Representatives Pimentel and
can you give him an answer since this
it's possible that representative Lang
has stepped away from his computer
we'll come back to that question when
representative McGee you recognize for a
question
yes
um limit the megawatts from so it's
basically covering now from between one
megawatt and two megawatts because I
think that exclusion will affect a
number of the municipalities who have in
excess of two megawatts and we're hoping
that we would be raising the net meter
and cap to the perk limit to you know
below five so and that was what was in
the original bill I was a co-sponsor on
this particular version
um
the net metering bill that came from
last session that we were trying to
accomplish for municipalities
help them basically lower their costs
and so I'm I'm that uh limitation I
don't know where it came from I guess
that's my question but I think that that
limitation will very much weaken the
bill in terms of the relief that it will
provide for those folks who are hoping
think of that question the the
limitation in the
16 of two Meg Watts came from discussion
with members of
the majority caucus
representative Lang testified in his
introduction as well he saw it as a
pilot program
yeah
[Applause]
Limited in nature make sure your
um
your microphone is muted
so anyway that's where that two
megawites megawatts came from
representative Lang if you are there
foreign
so you're saying that in in the majority
caucus the I the concept came up of a
pilot
um I think this particular legislation
for municipal net metering is in its
fourth year at least of trying to come
into being and the pilot maker would be
that we have pending municipalities
who've already made the Investments that
are looking to hold the costs by being
eligible which means that not
everybody's going to jump on this uh so
I I would push back to say that the idea
of a pilot is one idea but it's not
actually it doesn't really relate to
this bill because this bill is in
response to the fact that municipalities
have existing and you know pending
projects and existing projects that
would benefit from this if the cap were
higher than the two megawatts if it was
up to five so again I'm just advocating
for that because it didn't have this
exclusion before this go around
um and it was it was never intended to
be this low
so uh if it's a pilot it's a pilot
and if it's a municipal net metering
bill it's a municipal net metering bill
but I don't see how this
um limitation was just pulled out of
thin air and put into the bill because
it doesn't seem like it has any
relationship to the problem we're trying
to solve with the bill
thank you uh representative McWilliams
I I also have some concerns about this
reduction from the up to five megawatts
now we're going down to two megawatts
my understanding is that we have quite a
few existing Hydro facilities
um that have been surveying the
municipalities in schools for many years
they've been doing
um Hydro group net metering already
and they've been super excited about
this proposed bill with the five
megawatt cap and now we're dropping it
down to two megawatts sort of a surprise
and also a little unfair uh because they
were definitely getting ready to do this
um
so I I would just say that I I don't
think we need it uh I think that when
we're talking about pilot that would be
a phased in approach and I know we've
done this in past years when we're
talking about net metering we would say
okay two megawatts in here one three
megawatts and year two four megawatts
and you're free
Etc
um so perhaps we could come to a a fair
incremental approach for phasing in
rather than doing all this effort to
just go up by one megawatt when in
reality we've got Hydra chomping at the
bit at many municipalities who are
seeking to have this um
thank you for the comment I would
respond to that by saying that going
from one megawatt to two is sort of a
phase-in of a program
representative uh oxygen is recognized
for a comment
thank you Mr chair for taking my uh
discussion point
yeah I'm very concerned that we're a
step going back to a failed policy which
is one of putting caps on our programs
uh we've gotten rid of the cap this bill
uh goes puts the only effective barrier
is the one that ferc imposes which is
five megawatts instead of having these
perennial bills every year about lifting
the cap
we have a we have an opportunity to open
this up it's already limited you you the
bill is only applies to municipalities
um I I see no reason for for
re-establishing a cap
thank you
thank you representative Harrington is
thank you Mr chairman um I guess uh
since I believe this is still being paid
at the default service rate this is just
another way of transferring more money
and two megawatts is not as bad as five
but it's still worse than one
um there's a lot of municipalities
especially small towns that simply don't
have the capacity to go out and build
either they don't have a hydro facility
they simply don't have the load to go
out and build multi-megawatt systems and
consume all the power so they wouldn't
be eligible because you have to consume
as much as you produce over the course
of a year but during the times when
these uh systems are exporting power to
the grid which they're going to do at
some time that's the whole idea of the
net metering concept otherwise they just
reduce their load this would give them
default Service rates and it's simply
what they put out is not the same value
as default service rate if anyone wants
additional information on that I'd be
glad to give it to them but those two
are not equal that megawatt coming out
of the net metering uh facility whether
it's Hydro or solar is it does not have
the same value as the megawatt being
provided by the default service provider
there's so much more in the default
service system involving guarantee that
you must provide it all the time
matching load to supply and demand you
always have to make sure you you have
enough there you have to pay extra have
extra generators on standby you have
contracts with because you may or may
not need them but if you do uh you they
need to be there but you've got to pay
them one way or the other you have to
comply with the the renewable portfolio
standard and of course all these people
in there charge money the utilities have
to cover their costs uh that's all based
on the default service rate what comes
out of the net metering his no
obligation to provide anything they can
turn it on or turn it off whenever they
want and if it's at a time on a Sunday
morning that's sunny in in May when the
utility oil doesn't need any more
electricity they have to buy it that's
what the way it is and that's not a very
valuable product and we shouldn't be
paying default service rate they're
lucky to get it to one megawatt as far
thank you representative Representatives
thank you Mr chairman um
uh I
I understand the comment that represent
Harrington just made but I think that
that issue is something that we need to
talk about what a fair rate or net
metering is that's not what this bill is
about this bill is about
basically helping local New Hampshire
power generators
efficiently use what they can generate
and what they can share with
municipalities
to offset their their energy needs here
in New Hampshire without having to
import more of it from somewhere else uh
the fact that we're trying to limit New
Hampshire local power generation uh as
much as possible uh for places like the
uh like the monadnik paper mills and
other businesses and even towns that are
trying to uh uh partner with a local
Hydro for example uh to uh provide
service for the municipality I think we
should be doing everything possible to
encourage local power and creativity to
utilize New Hampshire's power generation
efficiently so it is this bill does
already limit it just to municipalities
it really should be expanded to all
businesses who think this might be an
opportunity for them as well so uh I
really think that that limiting it to
two two megawatts when even Nashua could
easily use more with their Hydro dams
right now and there are a number of
facilities throughout the state that are
looking into solar projects that would
exceed the two megawatt cap
uh if they could if it's a feasible and
financially reliable uh I think we're
limiting all these opportunities uh is
already quite quite a um detriment to
New Hampshire uh residents because we're
being dependent on on power from outside
our state why not encourage and utilize
them we don't need a pilot plant a
project here we have lots of towns who
already want to do this not just pilot
it but actually make it work so I I
really think that this bill limits that
opportunity
thank you uh representative Kelly Pitts
you will be next and I want to alert you
to the fact that I actually had to mute
you earlier because I think your
microphone is in fact working
so try it again uh
okay I'm not hearing you now but I was
hearing you earlier when you were out
out of your chair I was hearing can you
hear me yes yes
there you go I
yeah
I was I've been on the phone all along
no we heard you when you weren't on the
phone Jackie when you spoke into the
screen we heard you
and and the little red microphone's gone
away you hear me now yes yes we do
and you're recognize that question
or a comment
all right I'm gonna do what's convenient
for me right now okay uh I I think that
um
Nashua if I if I remember when could go
up to three possibly four megawatts
and not not wanting to do a bill just
for one individual or one town
I want to ask Mr representative
Harrington if he knows how many
State sources we have that would be
capable
of going up up to five megawatts so that
would be the four I would believe if we
put in four there we'd be fine and
that's to avoid control so
representative Harrington you recognized
are you there representative Harrington
you must have stepped away I'm sorry
Jackie
um let's see representative Samson's
recognized
we do have Heidi Chrome the line yeah
I'm sorry Mr chairman my hand is not
raised on I just forgot to take it down
okay thank you uh representative Thomas
is recognized
yes thank you Mr chair just for the
record uh for clarity
um
we're we're not limiting
the amount
that they can actually build I mean it's
something that's preventing them from
going the three or four megawatts but
yet the words I'm hearing is that we're
limiting them uh to to Ohio could you
clarify that difference for the record
yes basically this just limits the
amount that they can net meter
to two minutes not the amount that they
can build that you're absolutely right
about that right
uh Representatives hemantel is
recognized
thank you Mr chairman uh
first of all if we're talking about a
pilot program probably
Nashua would make a great pilot program
uh they certainly have the wherewithal
to be successful at it
and my other point is that if we're
if we're concerned about bringing it to
five megawatts because of
I don't know what
um but since there isn't even Nashua
doesn't approach five megawatts I guess
it's somewhere between three and four so
why not make it the five because that's
pretty much the legal limit
and just
let the thing let's get it out of
committee let's get it out of the the
house and let's let
uh LED it to do its job and um
uh we can just
stand back and watch it happen
thank you uh representative Platt is
recognized for a comment
all right I guess representative Herrick
had made the point earlier you raised
the limit your shifting crossed under
every other ratepayer we look like
Heroes when we reduce somebody's rates
like Nashua but it's on the backs of
everybody else and and so uh I think you
bet your answer this is not going to get
through with smoothly uh with a vote on
Monday so it's going to be routine
okay thank you for that point uh
I think my town is a is a town that has
uh invested in in solar on its you know
schools School roof panels and we also
have you know pellet burners in our
municipal buildings so we've made a lot
of conversions uh to get uh
you know to get going on our plans for
trying to get to zero emissions by 2050.
so like many towns we've tried to make
those plans work
what is not workable is is that the
amount of credit that you could be
earning if we had a proper net metering
program is is unavailable to give people
um the benefit of investing in local
sustainable clean energy sources which
is something we want to incent so the
way we're talking about it is that there
is a shift of costs if Hollis invests in
these things and then lowers its
electricity consumption because it is
generating local clean sustainable
energy and no longer purchasing that
energy from a fossil fuel producer
there is no shifting of costs there is a
lowering of the amount of costs that we
will be generating
and then there is the additional lowered
costs for the taxpayers in my town if we
are recouping money under a net metering
program that actually values the amount
of the energy that we're producing and
so that goes to representative
Harrington's point where he's saying the
value of a net metered energy should not
be equal to default service but that
value of net metered energy is
determined through a process that looks
at what is the value of a net metered
you know net metered energy so I think
that we're talking in circles on many of
the issues here there is no rate cost
shifting it's not a zero-sum game if my
town invests and lowers what we have to
pay for fossil fuels it doesn't go on to
your cost for fossil fuels fossil fuels
still costs what fossil fuels cost we've
just lowered Our Town costs and lowered
the rates of our utility bills for all
of the taxpayers in our town so that's a
goal Republicans and Democrats talk
about all the time is figuring out how
do we lower taxes
in municipalities and this the reason
we're supporting this bill and looking
to get this bill through at the highest
level possible is that
this is a vehicle where we can lower
costs
um people will have some
self-determination in being able to
lower their costs that's what's good
about it and so I would push back on the
idea that uh that the rate setting isn't
appropriate the way it's done I mean
there's people that that's all they do
is pay attention to that so it's it
isn't equivalent to uh to the default
service rate it's
set as a net meter grade which is
separate and distinct
um for that very reason but it does have
a value so I guess that's where the
argument seems to be between us is
whether
whether it should be valued
but I I disagree with the idea that if
if my town lowers its costs that
somebody else's town has to pick up
thank you representative oxenham is
thank you very much Mr chair for taking
my comment and for pointing out that it
is indeed a comment I do appreciate that
um yes as as to the points made by
representative McGee
what we're trying to do here what we're
trying to accomplish is lower the load
which at particularly lowering the load
at the time of peak which is when the
greatest charges are imposed Upon Our
those who are customers of the
electrical grid
and when you lower the peak you lower
costs to everyone the recently um the
synapse group brought out a study
looking at the cost of electricity in
New England and they found that the
value of renewable energy is greater
than the default service charge and it
they have a range of values in there but
even at the lowest it is in excess of
the default service charge so that that
really isn't an appropriate
representative McGee has pointed out
that the cost shifting argument is is
not a valid argument against this we are
in the midst of a transition to a clean
energy economy we have been working for
decades to increase the amount of
renewable energy to increase our Energy
Efficiency and in this year with what we
have seen with the Gulf Stream changes
with the wildfires you you all know the
litany and I won't list them here we
know we have to change the U.S Chamber
of Commerce has just come out with a
position paper
saying that climate is changing humans
are contributing to the changes we need
an effective climate policy and they're
looking for market-based Solutions
we need to be working together on this
and moving away from these old arguments
about cost shifting which have been
exploded again and again so please let
us move forward with this bill it's very
limited it only applies to the
municipalities
but we need to be getting rid of caps
and obstacles where they exist in
statute thank you
thank you representative
hemantel it's recognized for a comment
okay uh thank you Mr chairman uh kind of
reiterating a little bit what's said
here is it
any first of all we're not cost shifting
at all from the from uh these net meter
to other rate Pairs and if in fact we're
lowering the cost for everyone because
we're lowering uh transmission by
creating electricity locally and by
lowering transmission or lowering the
cost for every rate payer not just the
ones that are uh being net metered
I I think we have to just
uh look at this as benefits to everybody
the other thing is if you look at the uh
that transmission costs that
transmission cost is divided uh among
the the uh
uh participants and Reggie based on
percentages of uh electricity
transmitted
our other our neighbors are lowering
their transmission costs whereas we're
just kind of sitting there and so as a
percentage we're going to be paying a
higher and higher amount of that
percentage of the transmission costs
thank you representative Harrington is
recognized
don't forget to unmute representative
Harrington
okay representative Harrington doesn't
appear to be there so
representative Lang are you available
I am sir thank you very much I apologize
I was over at election law presenting a
bill I'm happy to answer any questions
or clarify things I've been listening to
the discussion for the last uh 10-15
minutes
earlier in the discussion uh
representative Pimentel had a question
about
the line in uh the bill that says a
municipal house shall be located in the
same municipality as all group members
if the facility begin operation after
January 1st 2020.
can you explain what that line means
absolutely so
um thank you thank you for letting me
answer this question so the intention
around this question is around uh
hydropower in that Hydro without
building any new Hydro but we want to
make Hydro available to be able to
consider itself a municipal Host this
would allow
um the hydro to be able to uh be able to
do that work uh do that act as a um
uh
Municipal host generator even if they're
um outside the municipality so I'll use
Bosque when as an example so if the
Bosque and hydro wanted to sell 100 of
its power to the city of Concord it's
not exactly like Bosco Hydro could pick
up their Dam and move it inside the city
of Concord but we want to give them the
opportunity to be able to participate in
that group that metering and as long as
they had 100 of one Community absorbing
that uh that energy and so by putting
that language in
um the idea was that
um someone like Bosque and hydro would
be able to sell to the city of Concord
as long as on the same grid provider or
same same provider
yeah
okay thank you so next up for a question
and I unmuted myself can you imagine
um I'm wondering if the uh thinking
about capacity for the um
whether a little thinking about capacity
that the utility has to maintain in the
face of
um you know the possible
um
uh accidents in these uh distributed
renewable energy
sites uh were there a discussion of that
we might make this thing a little easier
maybe a little more complicated but it
might be a little easier to take the uh
position of uh you know trying to uh
accommodate large
renewable systems
without you know necessarily affecting
uh or you know causing the utilities to
have to bear
an unreasonable or um
in a sense that they'd have to raise
their ability to
replace the Renewables if the Renewables
don't
um if they shut down for any reason and
the cost for that capacity would have to
be distributed
to everybody so I'm I'm going against a
lot of the discussion that uh my party
is talking about but if we just admitted
that and put that into the equation it
it might be a small matter and we could
stop worrying about it
thank you for that comment
um representative Callie Pitts is
recognized
representative Lang I had asked
representative Harrington a question but
and I'll get that probably I hope on
Monday but I'm going to ask you uh my
opinion is that government is the art of
compromise would you be willing to go
with fractions the way I learned them in
school and instead of going to two
make it three
uh megawatts because that would seem to
accommodate what you want to do would be
Nashville would be in a position to do a
a pilot at three megawatts I believe
that's what I heard
please forgive me I can't see so I can't
go back and look at my notes I mean I
can believe it not very well
so I believe that would work would you
accept three megawatts
so thank you for your question
instead of the two
so thank you for the question and I
guess I'm going to view this in the same
way we talked about this last year on
the same bill is I I if if two is what's
going to get it through the committee
with an OTP in the past and I'd rather
take the baby step and get the two if we
can get the three that's great but if it
three stops it from passing I don't want
I don't want three
um I I want to see progress made in this
industry I think we it's reliable and
one thing I'll remind everybody is that
when we're talking about Municipal house
generators we're talking about group
debt metering and that the consumption
has to be at 100 and so regardless of
what the number is we're not talking
about default Service rates at the end
of the year they have to True up how
much should they consume how much they
produce and if they produce more than it
consumes actually uh and they got paid
for it then they have to actually pay
money back to the utility
um to the wholesale rate if I'm not
mistaken and so
um I just want to remind that so we talk
about cost shifting that's not
necessarily happening here because again
this is group net metering in the
minutes when we're talking about
Municipal host generators
um grouping all the meters together
under one utility in their for it has to
be 100 your consumption has to be equal
to your generation and it's not really
talking about payments back to from the
um utilities
may I follow up
follow up
the only thing I wanted to say was that
again I think if we moved a little bit
maybe
and I can't speak for the other side but
I think maybe the other side is willing
to move forward a little bit more and we
can get this thing out with bipartisan
acceptance which I think would be a good
thing
that's all I agree you have all
reasonable people in the Science and
Tech committee that should be able to
work out the details
thank you Representatives uh
representative samstich is recognized
yes uh thank you Mr chairman
um yes I I so agree with uh represent
Kelly pitts's comment
um first of all uh representative Lang
just pointed out that in this this bill
because the municipality has to consume
its own energy there's absolutely no
chance of any kind of cost shifting
going on but the puc has already looked
at this issue of of net metering
shifting costs to other rate Pairs and
has said that officially that there is
no noticeable effect so this has already
been determined that there is no cost
shifting going on currently
um but represent Lang what I would like
to ask you is um
if you only have the two megawatt my
understanding is that doesn't help
Nashua too much am I incorrect
it helps them twice as much as they have
are able to do right now and I guess
that's you know I I'll take from one to
two any day from one to one so you know
it does does help it may not help as
much as they want and again as I said
sometimes it's the art of compromise and
moving some something forward rather
than nothing forward
um and and uh so again well I I would
use I put the bill in originally
uncapped because again I thought that uh
uh again because I knew it was group net
meter we weren't dealing with
um we were dealing with that 100
consumption from 100 of generations so
um I wasn't worried about it but if this
committee can come to an agreement other
than five or other than uh two that's
that's completely acceptable to me but
um and again I I the idea was not to
have the discussion about cost shipping
follow up Mr chairman yes follow up and
uh we'll be stopping in two minutes
okay just a clarification of represent
Lang
um when it comes to what the situation
is in Nashua currently what what is the
the maximum right now that they could
actually do
but my understanding is they'd be able
to group net they they could group net
meter up to up to a megawatt right now
if I'm not mistaken and then anything
over that would be a problem for him on
on I I think you misunderstood me what
I'm saying if there was a if there was
no cap what is Nashville currently able
to generate on their own from their
Hydro facilities I honestly don't know
the answer that I don't know what I I
don't know I do know they're about 20
municipalities throughout the state
looking to implement some sort of
um solar or uh or uh solar mostly uh
programs to help offset the rising
electricity costs to help the operating
budgets of those towns well I I did
visit Nashville I visited those Hydro
facilities there and my understanding is
from that visit that they could generate
anywhere between three and four
megawatts if they were allowed to if
there was no Camp involved
hey
okay thank you this has been a good
discussion
we're going to end it right now because
because reached our lunch break time
I need to uh do some communication with
the office of legislative services on HP
other people here have other commitments
so we will
recess this work session for the time
being we will resume at one o'clock when
we will have a presentation by the
Department of Environmental Services and
then after that presentation is over we
can resume discussion of this or any
other bills that we will be taking up on
Monday so everybody please enjoy your
lunch and we'll see you back here at one
o'clock
foreign
hi Mr Fitzgerald
good afternoon you're here on time
we try we strive
I just flew back in the door with my
husband we went for a walk at lunch and
no problem I'm glad I got out though be
a long day otherwise yeah well I
understand we're supposed to warm up
next week a little bit so uh
you don't enjoy it well he tells me
yeah you might want to check your email
real quick
hey cat or anybody else got a question
are we going to be doing any more any
more amendments for the rest of the
afternoon or are we pretty much asking
me doing a great
or doing the introduction to the DS
we're supposed to resume the this
mornings and then go on to the other
bills
okay my understanding
um okay
just wondering how to keep myself set up
here thanks
well
um Lee I see the message
um
there's also the small Hydro Association
note that indicates we probably don't
want to talk about this over the
broadcast I guess but I'm just saying
there's there's multiple groups that are
yeah yeah just
wanted to give you the heads up yeah I
it's it's all about heads up here isn't
it
I can
nosley saying hi
when we need a shout out for Jackie I
mean my God being on this thing after
going through eye surgery this morning
no oh dear
although she may be taking a break now
which should be well deserved
well at least he doesn't have to watch
the sausage being made hold on one
second hey were you guys saying hi to me
yeah
among other things
just want to say you know Lee you send
me that email a while back saying I hope
that everything was all right everything
is good I just had a major problem with
my house
yeah not fun no and uh I just came back
I had to move out last Wednesday me and
my wife
we went to a hotel a couple different
ones and we just arrived back yesterday
wow and uh we had a treatment done at my
house and I have like if as you can see
I have beams in my house
and uh
by the treatment what they did they did
some significant uh kind of damage but
what else we all we had to do what we
had to do but thank you very much for
everybody's concerned I really
appreciate it
um
and I'm sorry for not getting back with
you Lee
I'm going to say hello to Michael
Fitzgerald
this is John Mann good afternoon
representative pleasure to see you
I'm going to say good afternoon to Mr
Wright because I've heard so much about
you no yes everyone's looking for you
none of it's true
[Laughter]
to Fitzgerald we all
know hey I love it Mike Mike does a
great job down there as as long as you
folks thinks he's serving you well I'm
more than pleased to send them down
there uh Mr chairman I think you have
your mic is muted
all right let's get started uh uh 104.
yeah from now until whenever they're
finished I'm going to turn over the rest
of the or turn over the session to the
Department of Environmental Services who
will give us a presentation and help us
learn a lot about the programs that much
as the legislation we deal with affects
so without further Ado Mike Fitzgerald
of the Department of Environmental
Services air Resources Division the
floor is yours
good afternoon Mr chairman
um Mike Fitzgerald I'm the assistant
director of the air Resources Division
um pleased to be with you today I'm
joined by the director of the air
Resources Division Craig Wright I just
want to say at the outset um I
understand there's been some concern
about getting this presentation
scheduled and I want to acknowledge that
it was clear just simply my fault that I
missed the original invitation back in
January and uh by the time I was able to
connect with the chair and it was too
late to schedule so uh we want to
acknowledge it was uh not not an
oversight but we're pleased to be here
with you today
um and I'm going to turn this over to uh
director Wright
and uh he'll handle most of the
presentation uh he'll do the uh the hard
part and I'll do the the easy part at
the end and then uh I also am joined by
uh Catherine beam and Rebecca ohler at
the end
um perhaps Jennifer if you could uh
Elevate them to speaking in case there
are questions I might want to have them
uh respond in case you stump the Chumps
so
um with that I'll turn it over to Craig
uh thanks Mike hey it's really great to
see everybody uh I I ingest uh earlier
said it's great to have Mike down there
with you guys all the time and online
with you guys and I hope he serves you
well I know he does I I do listen in on
occasion to what he has to say so thanks
Mike for being representative of the air
division down at St e greatly appreciate
it
um Mike could you go slide please sure
so we have about 30 35 slides we'll try
to run through them I I don't think
it'll take more than a minute to slide
and we're certainly available for
questions
um if you have questions during the
presentation feel free to interrupt or
uh probably use you to go right to the
end and then have questions but we'll
leave that up to the committee's choice
so anyways what you see here is a
functional log chart of the Year
division
um before I talk about that though I did
want to mention uh similar to most of
you the air division is largely working
in a remote environment due to covid uh
we've been about 90 95 percent of our
staff have been working from home for
almost a year now it's hard to believe
um I think we would assess uh besides
getting out of the building and getting
people transitioned to a new work
environment I would say we've been
highly effective and highly efficient
and uh can't be more pleased with how
our staff has performed uh during this
time so and with that I'll just quickly
point out we have three bureaus and a
director's office our permitting
environmental health Bureau obviously
this is where you come get an air permit
whether it's a state permit or a federal
permit you come to Des you don't need to
go to EPA we can hit we can handle all
Air permit needs there's about 40
chapters of air regulations that are
applicable to our regulated community
and there are literally hundreds of
federal standards as well so we do a lot
of technical assistance and Outreach to
our regulated Community we also have an
environmental health program here this
is important to point out because this
group not only serves the air division
but also serves the Water Division and
the waste divisions as well so this is a
a we've got two new positions a couple
years ago out of the pfas situation
going on to do some toxicology work and
we've just re-established our atsdr
environmental health program that we
have lost funding for back in 2017 so
really proud there our compliance Bureau
this is our boots on the ground these
are the people out in the field these
are the people doing the inspections uh
climbing the stacks witnessing the stack
tests this is our emissions inventory
group our enforcement group we also have
an asbestos demo demo rental program
that is run through the year Division
and that's in our compliance Bureau as
well Technical Services Bureau it's kind
of our catch-all Bureau that's the where
Mike cut his teeth in the air division
uh coming out of the technical services
Bureau this is our mobile Source
programs this is our air monitoring I'll
be talking about that in a minute uh
this is where we have our clean energy
programs uh this is obviously where we
house our Reggie program that most of
you are probably familiar with and a lot
of our legislative activity has tracked
this Bureau and hence that's why you see
Mike lot and that's currently headed up
by Becky oler as well then we have the
director's office uh one thing we know
about air pollution that doesn't it
doesn't end New Hampshire's borders and
doesn't start at New Hampshire's borders
so we have to play a role both
regionally and nationally to ensure that
our air is clean here in New Hampshire
as well next slide Mike
this is just our contact information for
our senior senior staff in the in the
division stops right at the top here
that's why we only have two numbers
listed you feel free to call any of
those other folks but also feel free to
call me and Mike with on any issues and
we'll get we'll get you pointed in the
right direction uh so feel free to reach
out to us Mike next
so just a quick overview of what we do
in addition to the all the state laws uh
that regulate air boost in New Hampshire
it's really important to note that the
air division has taken on the vast
majority and has been delegated most of
the federal programs under the Clean Air
Act Amendments of 1990. included in that
responsibility is our requirement to
monitor air quality of the state I have
a slide coming up on that so I won't
talk much about that it's really up to
the state EPA sets the Hep this
health-based standards that we need to
meet if we fail to meet them it's up to
the state to come up with programs and
ways to implement control strategies to
meet those federal act quality standards
so we spend an awful lot of time working
with EPA again
state and federal air permits again
One-Stop shop here you come Des don't
need to go see EPA uh again compliance
inspections were out in the field we
negotiated an annual inspection plan
with EPA EPA oversees our enforcement
activities we go through periodic audits
on both those inspection programs and on
our enforcement programs and I'm very
pleased to say that we very rarely get
any significant comments from EPA so
we're doing our good we're doing a good
deed
our AMD staff we have 69 full-time
positions 16 of them are currently
vacant that's almost one out of uh one
out of four uh is vacant here in the
division we are trying to fill some
positions right now of course with
coveted similar to most state agencies
uh we had some issues with being able to
fill positions for a while but we are
moving to fill
um at least four of those positions
right now
um this is a a constant struggle as
keeping positions filled in state
government
um in terms of Staffing we have a lot of
Engineers rather the mechanical chemical
civil very technical reviews that we do
on the permitting side we have
environmental and Life Sciences folks
atmospheric sciences Health Sciences and
we even have a couple attorneys on staff
as well so a highly professional highly
dedicated staff of individuals Mike next
slide
this just gives you a sense of our
Revenue sources
um if you look at this bar chart the
first thing you would probably know
going back almost going back 11 years
here this is relatively flat we have not
seen increased revenues in the air
division for over 10 years uh anybody
who knows understands math and the
economy uh what you could buy in FY 10
for 7 million dollars a year and what
you can buy an FY 20 two different
things the rate of inflation the cost of
keeping staff on board so we've been
relatively flat funded for over 10 years
our biggest source of Revenue is those
blue bars that's our permitted sources
our regulated Community they pay almost
50 percent of the operating budget of
the air division our second biggest
funding source is the federal government
those little green bars a little mix in
with the yellow bar those are minor
programs mobile sources although mobile
sources Remain the biggest source of
emissions in the State uh they're
relatively small part of our Revenue
generation you'll notice a little bit of
an increase in the red bar which is a
general fund program funding for the
division that didn't increase in FY 18
and 19 as I mentioned those two new
positions that came on board related to
pfos in addition there was some support
of our air permit program through FY 19
20 21 we expect that will be gone in the
next budget looking out to 22.23 so
you'll see that red bar probably shrink
a little bit in the future years
so very much dependent on fees and the
federal government to maintain our
programs
um we believe that maintaining good air
quality is important for the environment
and we think it's important for the
economy
um one of the things under the Clean Air
Act is if you don't meet the federal air
quality standards it's up to the state
to come up with rules and regulations
and you know who's who who's going to be
the subject of that it's going to be our
regulated sources it's going to be our
industry it's going to be part of our
economic base so it's it's our best
interest to meet the federal air quality
standards that of course is the public
health costs um obviously pair poor air
quality means increased health care
costs for New Hampshire especially as an
aging State we know one thing air
pollution disproportionately impacts The
Young and the elderly in terms of impact
so and good air helps our forests let's
face it to have a healthy Forest need
good air a healthy Forest means
maintaining soils in place controlling
runoff means clean water so I think it's
all interconnected and I think we're
very pleased to play our role we all
know New Hampshire is a beautiful state
people come here for our mountains our
views our clean Lakes well it all ties
back to the economy in my mind so very
important linkage there
next slide Mike
uh clean air activity this is really
like I said has been the driving force
um I actually started in 1988 at the
division and so I've seen the amount of
changes and regulations that came out of
the Clean Air Act amendments in 1990 one
of the things EPA does is set what we
call these National ambient air quality
standards for the criteria pollutants
they're listed there we pretty much have
had some sort of issue with every one of
those pollutants at some time going back
uh into the early 70s and 80s at one
point carbon monoxide used to be the big
problem due to motor vehicle traffic up
north I mean sorry the southern part of
the State uh sulfur dioxide was an issue
around the Merrimack power station for
for a number of years ozone's been our
biggest Boogeyman uh since I've been
around uh has been our biggest
regulatory driver it's been our biggest
challenge particular matter I think is
the potential pollutant of the future
um I think that's one that's gonna
continue to get more and more attention
as we move forward into the future EPA
also regulates hazardous air pollutants
New Hampshire that's a technology-based
program where EPA sets technology
standards for certain size sources and
then they need to meet certain control
criteria New Hampshire has its own air
toxics program that's more of a
health-based program where we have
health-based standards for over 600 air
pollutants air toxins
one thing about the naxes to recall
remember is that the science doesn't sit
still on impacts of air pollution
um on on the human body and human health
EPA is required to review the Knacks
every five years they generally get more
astringent over time as science gets
better as is a better understanding of
how air pollution impacts the human
health so EPA doesn't always meet that
five-year Target I'll be honest with you
uh but they are going through this
process right now on a couple of the
again just this issue of attainment
non-attainment non-attainment is
probably not really a word in the
regular dictionary but it is a big word
in the air pollution World
um this means if you're not
entertainment means you don't meet those
Federal health-based standards uh that
triggers a whole slew of requirements on
the state we've lived that primarily
through ozone for the past 20 years I
can say we are now currently attainment
which is good for New Hampshire we're in
a maintenance mode it doesn't mean we
don't occasionally have poor air quality
uh but it's it's the better of the two
places to be into in two I can assure
you with that uh we're kind of in a
maintenance mode at some level but we
can't backslide the Clean Air Act does
not allow you to go backwards so we need
to continue our due diligence and
regulating air pollution in the state
in terms of our federal money we get
from EPA this is where we probably spend
the most of our federal money on our air
monitoring program we monitor air
quality literally from the top of Mount
Washington uh to the base of Mount
Washington down the Connecticut River
Valley across the Southern Tier over the
Seacoast in up the Merrimack River
Valley
you can see on the left the pollutants
that we March before we don't monitor
for all those pollutants at every site
these are very scientifically chosen
sites for example some people would say
why are you monitoring up on top of
Mount Washington well Mount Washington
Believe It or Not sometimes has some of
the worst ozone pollution in the state
generally that's early in the season uh
that's an indicator of probably Air
transport into the state uh that's one
of the reasons we like to monitor at
high elevations we also have a second
high elevation site in the southern part
of State on top of back when that dock
but like for example Lebanon we monitor
ozone there we don't monitor any other
pollutant there Laconia we monitor ozone
and we are doing some temporary
monitoring on carbon monoxide so in
Pembroke we only monitor for SO2 uh we
have that's just downwind of the
Merrimack station power plant
um so that's literally a monitor cited
to monitor uh One Source in the state so
um Nashville obviously is one of our
congested areas same with Portsmouth and
Rye so this is very indicative of our
heavily uh populated parts of the state
so next slide Mike
this is just some examples of our
monitoring sites uh Miller State Park
um in Londonderry I'd like to point
those two out to people uh we use these
as educational sites if possible uh
Pac-Man Miller State Park obviously sees
a lot of foot traffic up there we try to
uh communicate with the traveling public
on the benefits of long-term Trail
pollution and what they can do to help
air pollution I would say each one of
these sites probably has somewhere in
the neighborhood of probably a quarter
of a million dollars worth of equipment
inside of it
um
a lot of the money we spend on this
program is Manpower related uh we do
spend some money on new equipment we
primarily get that through Capital
funding
the area permitting program again this
is a One-Stop shop for anybody who needs
a permit uh we have almost 800 permanent
facilities in the state 30 of them are
the federal permits required that's our
title five sources these are your big
Power Plant your large industrial
sources and then we have uh over 770
State sources a couple things I'll point
out here
415 General permits for emergency
generators and the 86 permit by
notifications on Rock crushing
operations those are completely online
permitting processes and we're really
proud and that's something we're going
to continue to try to expand upon for
our other 269 sources there is to try to
get them into the online permitting
process as well
um that was just a picture of Merrimack
station there I'm sure many of you seen
that as you drive up and down Route 93
right through here in Concord so uh Mike
next slide
again our compliance permit program we
spend an awful lot of time out in the
field again negotiating with EPA uh the
sources we're going to conduct despite
covet in 2020 largely we can still
conducted 82 Source inspections they
were modified uh they were more uh
enhanced record reviews site
surveillance that type of stuff less
in-person
inspections we are looking at doing some
sort of remote inspections in the future
something we're watching some of our
states especially out west the largest
states tend to do a lot more remote
inspections so we'll take taking
advantage of Technology that's something
we're gonna hopefully do in the future
as well we have we responded to over 88
complaints in 2020 uh we go out and do
the stack tests uh generally companies
hire a third party where they had to
observe witness oversee verify uh the
test is done correctly in accordance
with EPA standards we did that at 51
sites in 2020 again despite uh covid
that was a very normal number in terms
of uh the number of sites we go do tests
at
um enforcement I just listed this for
2019 I don't have the data for 2020 yet
but the important thing is we were able
to close out 77 enforcement actions all
without Federal over filing that's
always our goal is to manage New
Hampshire sources as a state agency uh
and not to have EPA come into our state
um asbestos management mentioned that in
addition to our normal demo rental
program we also have what we call the
Asbestos and schools program we have a
small Grant from EPA we generally do 30
inspections every year at schools that
have asbestos in them
um you would you would think the rules
would say get rid of the asbestos it
doesn't necessarily say that says manage
it properly and that's what we make sure
that they're out there managing it
properly uh obviously for the safety of
the school school children
next slide Mike
it just hit on a couple of my major uh
mobile Source programs mentioned mobile
sources remain our largest source of
emissions uh car emissions are actually
uh regulated at the federal level or in
some instances California and other
states may join what California does New
Hampshire does not do that most of the
states around us are in fact Cal Lev or
follow the California program New
Hampshire does not have that
um that's a matter obviously a policy
decision of the legislature uh OBD
that's everybody's favorite check engine
light program uh highly effective
cost-effective program for ensuring that
cars are running as cleanly as designed
uh all the department of safety runs
that we work in conjunction with them we
analyze the data we're responsible for
reporting that data to EPA to make sure
that that program's run properly Granite
State Clean Cities Coalition this is a
great stakeholders group we have over
150 Partners run right here through our
our own Jessica Wilcox here at the air
division uh the the purpose of this
group is to help facilitate and uh work
our way off of uh fossil fuels in our
transportation sector so a really great
stakeholder uh group that we got going
on Adair diesel emission reduction act
this is a Federal grant we administer on
behalf of EPA uh we helped fund the
replacement of the older diesel
equipment uh we don't pay 100
replacement costs a lot of cases up to
25 40 percent replacement costs this is
federal funds that we passed through uh
so this is a program that we've also
leveraged with the VW funding uh if
people remember the VW emission Scandal
a couple years ago that's actually run
through OSI office of strategic
initiative but we we've kind of we're
kind of contracted with them to be the
technical arm so we do a lot of work for
them on behalf of ew we're currently
working with them on a
RFP to come out soon on the build out of
EV charging along our major corridors I
think this is an area where New
Hampshire is lacking in comparison to
our neighbors so being able to spend
that 15 of the VW money on that is going
to be huge we also work with regional
planning commissions uh so next slide
Mike
I'll note again I started in 1988 so
this is right after I started so I'll
take all the credit here now just
kidding of course uh what we're seeing
here is a 30-year emissions Trends
across New Hampshire the blue bar is
carbon monoxide that goes actually with
the right side scale and all the other
pollutants knocks sulfur dioxide PM 10
PM 2.5 and vocs the green the yellow the
red the blue and the black and the gray
all go to the left side but what you're
seeing here is Mike if you just click
once
yep so over 30 years we've seen anywhere
from a 50 reduction to over a 95
reduction in some of these pollutants
this is obviously the result of the uh
you know state laws obviously the result
of the clean act amendments in 1990 this
is good news for New Hampshire we're
cleaning up our own emission sources
we've done a great job one we still have
work to do
um the other thing I'd point out on this
this is just in-state emissions as we
know uh pollution doesn't stop at the
boundaries so uh we still have to deal
with transported air pollution to the
state but this is obviously a very good
trend for New Hampshire
so this is a rather unique way of
looking at well how good is the air
quality in New Hampshire and each one of
these bars represents one of our
counties in New Hampshire it also the
11th bar on the right yes there's not 11
counties in New Hampshire the 11th bar
on the right is our high elevation site
so that would be that Pacman ad knock
site and also Mount Washington the top
of Mount Washington so green means good
air quality yellow means moderate orange
means unhealthy for sensitive gender
sensitive groups that would be when
we're violating the federal air quality
standards so by and large New Hampshire
is we have pretty good air quality about
85 to 90 percent of our days uh some
days we're moderate very occasionally
with the USG if I put this up for 10
years ago you would see probably 10 15
20 days a year would be USG what you're
seeing here for 2018 and 2019 is
probably an average of five or less USG
days again that's a really good
indicator that we're making great
progress but I will point out one thing
though poor air quality is still in New
England Connecticut still has some of
the worst ozone uh in the in the country
uh Connecticut's not that far away from
us so we still need to maintain you do
I've kind of already hit on this a
little bit but obviously our biggest
issue has been ozone it's a summertime
pollutant we don't
our sources don't directly emit ozone
it's it's formed in the atmosphere as a
combination of strong sunlight high
temperatures uh nitrogen oxide emissions
and VOC emissions so a lot of what we
get in New Hampshire is transported
um ozone pollution we tend to see it at
Ohio elevations or along our seacoasts
when we get the or come basically what
comes out of Boston is a plume fine
particular matter this is primarily a
wintertime pollutant the post a child of
this is wood smoke in the Keen valley
during the winter time and I have a
slide coming up on that so I won't spend
much time there one of the other big
things we're working on right now and
again I still think fine particular
matter is going to be a bigger pollutant
of concern in the future as as science
gets caught up with health-based
standards uh Regional Haze this is this
is really not a health issue it's a
quality of life issue New Hampshire has
what we call two class one areas in the
state up in the White Mountains class
one areas get special protections under
the Fed Clean Air Act and the goal of
the regional Haze program is to restore
visibility in those areas to background
Levels by 2064. I probably will not be
the air director in 2064. I hate to say
it but uh we do know we're in our second
10-year planning phase of that right now
so we anticipate putting a new rule out
uh very shortly by the end of this month
hopefully our climate clean energy is
obviously a a great concern to the
division clean energy of course our
interest there is uh energy is is
invariably in a lot of cases a very
intensive pollution source so uh we see
a clean a big link between climate air
pollution and clean energy
Mike next slide I won't spend a lot of
time on this this is just for
educational purposes and and we could
certainly make these slides available
but I mentioned ozone it's not directly
admitted there's good old Zone in this
battle Zone though ozone way up above
the old ozone layer we've heard about
from the 80s that was falling apart that
protects us from UV radiation from the
Sun that's good ozone battle zone is the
ozone that forms near the ground that's
commonly also a lot of people would call
that a smog and again it's been our
largest regulatory driver here in the
state Mike next
ozone obviously is a respiratory issue
of respiratory concern asthma bronchitis
emphysina again it really impacts our
younger folks who have a much higher
respiratory rate than us adults and it
also significantly impacts our older
population or anybody who deals with
asthma
um as I know as New Hampshire has some
of the highest asthma rates in the
country from what I understand so
um next slide Mike
one of the things Congress did recognize
when they passed the ozone uh the uh
Clean Air Act Amendments of 1990 is the
fact that no one stayed alone in the
Northeast was going to be able to
control ozone due to the fact that ozone
is such a regional pollutant so they
created what's known as the ozone
transport region this is still a
regulatory driver in New Hampshire even
though we are in attainment with the
ozone standard there are certain
components of the Clean Air Act we still
need to implement as if we were
non-attainment and that that's literally
right in the Clean Air Act because of
this ozone transport region we need to
make sure that we don't that our
emissions are clean for our own purposes
but we can't impact downward States as
well so
uh next slide Mike
another six another success story here
this just looks at ozone precursors in
New Hampshire this would be our vocs and
Knox emissions nitrogen oxide emissions
my source category blue is points to us
that's the Smoke Stack Industries red
being our area sources that would be you
and I
um uh mowing our Lawns and other things
or consumer products and things like
that
um and then mobile sources our
transportation sector uh we can see
we've made tremendous strides here we're
you know a third of where we were just
in 1996 in terms of total emissions
um our smokestack Industries have very
much cleaned up their emissions again
that blue bar on the bottom uh
Transportation Still Remains our uh our
biggest source and and probably still
the toughest uh issue to crack so next
the long range story in Ozone as I
mentioned is good if you look at the
slides a little complicated but if you
see the red checkered line that is the
federal standard the eight hour standard
you can see you can see the impact of
EPA reviewing that every five years or
so as science has gotten better better
understanding of impacts of ozone on
people you can see how the standard has
dropped a couple times since 1996 and
that's the result of those periodic
reviews that EPA has done we're
currently at the 70 parts per billion on
the far right hand side
prior to 1996 you might say well where's
the red line the red line back then the
standard was on a one-hour basis rather
than an eight-hour basis so it'd be a
little deceiving to put it on this same
chart of data
um but I think it's very clear you can
see the trend is clearly downward uh in
our ozone numbers across the state so
next slide Mike
fine particular matter this is a PM 2.5
again this is where I think the future
may
we may have some challenges on the left
side of that is a human hair which is 70
microns on the right side gives you an
idea of looking at a cross section of
that here what PM 2.5 and pm10 looks
like we are talking tiny tiny particles
of either liquids or small particular
matter these things are so small PM 2.5
it gets deep into our lungs
um and that's that's the issue I think
is the the depth to which it can
penetrate into the lungs and they can
also penetrate into the cardiovascular
system so it's not just a lung issue
it's also a heart issue as well
Mike
and this just talks about some of the
impacts we can probably jump over that
Mike
p.m 10 PM 2.5 Trend in New Hampshire
again uh the red dotted line shows the
federal standard uh again you can see
the result of EPA revising the standard
in 2006 it went from 65 micrograms per
cubic meter to 35. that was a very
significant drop in 2006.
um again that's based on current health
sciences I will be interested to see
where this number ends up in the future
um I think this is an area we may see
some downward trending of the standard
in the future uh what whether that
happens in the next year or 10 years I
don't know but science does seem to have
a strong indication that PM is is is an
ongoing health issue the line underneath
kind of shows you where we've been as a
state this is primarily the Keen data
this is a little bit deceiving because
it looks like we're always below that
line
there's a little bit of a disconnect in
the standard uh in my opinion the
standard
the 35 number there is based on a
midnight to midnight reading that's the
way the EPA Federal standard is set
midnight to midnight most of our high PM
nights in Keene happen over the Midnight
Hour so literally what the standard does
is it takes one event and kind of
divises into two parts
if you had a rolling 24-hour number as
opposed to a midnight to midnight that
blue line would be significantly higher
and possibly above the red line but
technically we're in attainment
um and we and we continue to see a
downward Trend which is definitely a
good thing so Mike next slide
uh back in 2008 2009 we were really
concerned about the wood smoke situation
in Keene we were very close to the
standard we were close to going into
non-attainment as you looked at that
previous graph uh one of the things we
were able to do is facilitate over a
five-year period two wood stove
changeout programs the first one was in
2009 we used some supplemental uh
environmental uh payment from A Fine
from American Electric Power a lawsuit
that New Hampshire was involved in and
we changed 86 old wood stoves in 2009 in
in the city proper of Keene with new EPA
compliant wood stoves next slide Mike
that was at a cost of about a hundred
and six thousand dollars
in uh 2015 2016 Bridgewater power funded
a four hundred thousand dollar wood
stove changeout program under the New
Hampshire renewable portfolio standards
program uh this was a first of its kind
program in New Hampshire funded under
that mechanism
um and then that that was Cheshire
county-wide not just Keene but we were
able to change out almost 300 wood
stoves we basically worked through the
American Lung Association who ran the
program for us but you can see we got
four hundred thousand dollars over 300
wood stoves changed out so next slide
Mike
this is just what we used to see in
Keene on a regular basis
um it's a little hard to see on this
picture but if you look to the left and
the right you can see the mountains in
the background there
um and in the foreground what you do see
is wood smoke actually trapped by a
thermal inversion uh within the Keen
Valley so this is one of the first times
we were able to get an actual picture of
it we could always monitor it but in
this day early in the morning one of our
staff was out there and we were able to
get this picture so that that is clearly
would smoke trapped within the valley
region so
Regional Haze I mentioned before this is
this is the this is not a health program
this is a quality of life program
um if you look on the right
you can see a good a good day in terms
of visibility and you look on the right
you see a very poor day of visibility
that's not that's not uh rain in there
that's not collagen there that's fine
particles either sulfur particles or
nitrogen particles uh reflecting the
light uh in parent visibility this is
the intent of uh of the regional Haze
program again this goes out to 2064 but
it's a program we're implementing in New
Hampshire as a class one state and we
work with a much larger group called
main view which is the northeast states
working together on this issue and we've
had asks as far away as Texas for uh
companies to try to clear up their Smoke
Stacks because of their potential impact
on Regional age of New Hampshire
and with that I'm going to yield the
floor to Mr Fitzgerald finally who you
all know very well and he's going to go
over our Reggie program and talk a
little bit about uh where we are as a
division on pfas and then we're
certainly open to questions
good thanks I appreciate it
I'm sorry
oh go for it okay I'm getting a little
echo in here but uh okay they're almost
set now
um good thank you Craig appreciate that
and uh the good news is we're near the
end uh I only have a few slides left
here so uh Reggie program you had some
legislation on this this year and some
discussion unfortunately we weren't able
to provide this information to you prior
to so hopefully this will resonate uh
the Reggie program uh is a an initiative
of uh the Northeast and Mid-Atlantic
States uh back in the
2004-2005 time frame
um has continued since and uh and we're
actually the good news is that actually
expanding uh recently have added
Virginia New Jersey dropped out for a
while and is now back and there are
actually there are some discussions
possible uh inclusion of Pennsylvania at
some point down the road here so how
does Reggie work first
you identify the sources that have to be
covered in the Reggie program in the
states that are participating those are
25 megawatt or greater fossil fuel
powered plants New Hampshire has a few a
few such sources and so it became
pertinent for us to be part of this
program
you determine their emissions we did
this back in as I say the 2004-2005 time
frame what their missions were and then
we set a cap
and uh the then we issue allowances a
ton of CO2 is equivalent to an allowance
so therefore we issued allowances
equivalent to what the current level
emissions were and those allowances are
distributed by an auction it was
determined that that's the most
efficient economically efficient way to
to handle that we have a regional
auction of those allowances can be
purchased by compliance entities and
then
um
in the auction there is there are
Provisions to uh
ensure that the cost of allowances don't
don't go up too too much and there's a
trigger provision and then
uh the compliance entities can purchase
trade and Bank those allowances and then
at the point of compliance they the
sources must true up so however much
they've omitted and usually the
compliance period is a three-year period
the sources have to determine how much
CO2 they've emitted report that and then
they have to uh surrender allowances
equivalent to that so the that makes
them purchase those allowances the
allowances as I say are distributed in
an auction and the auction revenues go
back to the states and the states use
those in a variety of ways
significant amounts of it are moved to
Energy Efficiency in order to to
reduce greenhouse gas emissions from the
electricity sector in New Hampshire we
as was indicated to you on the in a
testimony on the legislation on Reggie
this year significant portion of the the
New Hampshire revenues are refunded back
to Consumers and to uh corporations to
the companies and Commercial entities
about one dollar for every ton of
allowance
um is allocated to Energy Efficiency
programs here allowances currently
trading uh the auction 51 for Reggie was
just held yesterday and allowance is
traded at about seven dollars and sixty
cents
so in New Hampshire's case we use one
dollar of that seven dollars to go into
our Energy Efficiency programs and the
remainder is rebated to Consumers
for their own benefit so
um that's basically how the program
works and also just wanted to very
briefly touch on uh the pfas issue many
of you have heard of
significant prefast contamination in
Southern New Hampshire as a result of
some industrial emissions down there
that it's gone on for many many years
back in in 2018 we worked with this
committee and numerous other committees
and and legislators to get SB 309 passed
SB 309 requires us to regulate emission
sources of pfas that have the potential
to contaminate groundwater
um and it requires require required us
to put a uh a permit in place excuse me
and require controls from One Source in
New Hampshire the saint gobain plant
down in Merrimack
many of you may have heard
um there's been some Rumblings recently
uh relative to that situation and Des
has filed suit to ensure compliance and
is working closely with the facility to
ensure that they move as expeditiously
as possible
so uh that bill also required us to
establish some groundwater
drinking water mcls and we're called
agqs ambient groundwater quality
standards for 4p fast compounds I will
not uh go over those you can read them
on your own and we have established
those standards and the standards are
established per RSA 485 16e which was
Again part of Senate bill 309.
uh Des also is required to develop a
plan for surface water quality standards
by January 1st 2020
um and we also received some general
funds as Craig mentioned
um we've received an increase in our
general fund allocations to help hire a
risk assessor and a toxicologist to
conduct studies and other work to
support development of those standards
and also for Des
um is if we the legislation required us
to update the every five years our
ambient groundwater quality standards
many of which we haven't had staff and
uh under the resources to update and
have not been revised since back in the
late 80s and early 90s so that's a task
that we're currently working on and
we're very pleased with the staff that
we've been able to hire to uh to do that
work so um and we're making we're making
significant progress we should have that
done by the deadline in 2023 it was
established
uh again
um we did Issue a permit for single Bain
uh a year ago in February
they requested a variance to that they
cited covid issues and um uh some other
con issues on uh causing them delays in
construction
um we denied that variance uh back last
summer and um the permit uh was
subsequently appealed by the town of
Merrimack and uh those controls were
still required the permit's still in
effect and they were required to be
installed back in February
and again we are working with the source
to um to ensure that they do so
expeditiously they have not met the
permit requirement but they are they are
working and and we're discussing with
them how we're going to respond to their
failure to meet the that requirement
um we have also identified other
facilities that need stack testing and
to date we have not identified any other
facilities that we think would be
subject to this legislation
[Music]
um there's currently an LSR over in the
Senate that would ban incineration of
pfast it's very widely the term pfas and
incineration is very broadly
defined we've expressed some significant
concerns about that legislation and how
it might interfere with the application
of RSA 125 c10e and we are currently
discussing that with the with the
sponsors so hopefully we can get that
corrected before it comes up across over
to the house and get it to a point that
would not interfere with these the
situation that we're experiencing down
um so again uh I told you we would be
brief
um uh director Wright and I are
certainly available at any point in time
as Craig mentioned to you he comes out
of the permitting side I come from the
technical sources climate energy side
and um uh so between the two of us we
might be able to uh Cobble together one
good answer to a question and uh if not
we have great staff and I also have uh
Catherine beam uh here with us today
Catherine is in charge of our ship
planning and uh used to be in permitting
she's been very involved and is an
actually nationally renowned expert on
pfas emissions so if you have any
questions in that Arena Catherine is
available and also Rebecca oler many of
you know Becky um as well Becky's in
charge of our climate energy programs
um and uh so if there are questions with
regards to our reference in those Arenas
um I may if again if you stump Craig and
I we uh we may ask them to jump in but
with that um I think we're uh we're
finished Mr chairman and we'd be happy
to uh to take questions from you or the
committee and we thank you for the
opportunity to uh to share our
information with you today
thank you
um
[Music]
I'm getting a really weird Echo I'm
sorry Mr chairman I'm not able to
understand yeah the questioner is uh and
we can't we can't hear any other
here
[Music]
I can hear you now yes
can you stop sharing
I
[Music]
this thing do you have any idea what's
okay is the echo gone now
yeah
yeah okay I muted you Mr Fitzgerald I
think the echo is coming from you uh so
I'm going to let people ask questions
and then I'll turn you back on so or
allow you to turn yourself back on so
you can answer so the first questioner
is representative oxen
thank you very much a quick question
about electric vehicles and mobile
sources in general uh there was a a
statement made I Believe by uh Mr Wright
about the importance of reducing
pollution in for mobile sources being a
particularly difficult nut to crack
um do you see in in the coming years of
advantages to moving to electric
vehicles uh We've we've had the opinion
expressed here in committee that this is
something of a fad
oh I don't I don't think it's a fad I
Think electric vehicle is a common uh
there's no doubt about it in my mind uh
look at the way some of the main the
lodge manufacturers are talking I think
Volvo just announced they won't sell a
non-electric car in 20 past 20 30. um I
think this is the transition we're
coming to I think you're seeing a lot of
the big automakers invest in this I
think we got to get over the buyer
concern issue we need to build the
infrastructure uh to let people feel
comfortable buying electric vehicles
most people who have electric vehicle
charge at home so they can take care of
their own charging it's when they're on
the road traveling that they have
concerns so we need to build out the
infrastructure along our travel ways and
I wish I had the map I know Becky has a
map where it shows uh fast charges in
New Hampshire compared to our states
around us and we almost look like a
donut hole we are falling behind on
building the infrastructure and I'm I am
particularly excited about uh the um us
the governor agreeing with OSI to spend
the 15 of the VW money on uh
infrastructure for electric vehicles I
think that's a start uh I don't think
that's the end game I think we need to
invest more so where the revenue comes
for that that's the big question so
Becky or Mike I don't know if you want
apparently not so I'll ask a follow-up
question to that question do you think
that
building charging infrastructure would
be better accomplished by private
companies
who can make a profit from
putting together those stations rather
than perhaps the government be involved
I would say probably anytime you could
leverage private funding that's
obviously a good thing
um I think like the VW funding I think
what we're talking about is getting
something off the ground uh building
some infrastructure but then third
parties running those so they would
ultimately uh hopefully build a model
where they could uh they could make a
profit off it and expand the
infrastructure themselves I mean you got
to start somewhere though
thank you representative samsitch it's
recognized
yes thank you Mr chairman
um
we've got actually two questions I think
um just as a uh um in the way of
explanation uh the the Reggie auction of
um
renewable energy certificates
um I'm currently involved with selling
my solar wrecks to an aggregator and the
price that I'm getting for my Rex is um
over thirty dollars or a wreck and you
mentioned uh that right now in New
Hampshire uh we're getting something
like 7.50
can you explain the difference of where
that big discrepancy comes from Mike do
you want to explain that or I could
sure
um yeah you're speaking uh actually of
two different programs renewal renewable
energy certificates are
um the results from the renewable
portfolio standard
um they are certificates that are issued
for each hour of Renewable Power that is
generated in in the state from solar
wind various uh types of entities uh
Reggie allowances are a different
um
uh entity uh Reggie allowance is the
equivalent of one
um ton of CO2 emissions from a power
plant and so they're just two completely
different entities Reggie allowances
currently traded around seven dollars
and eighty cents yeah the rec Market is
vastly different but their their apples
and oranges
thank you a follow-up Mr chair oh
uh also I'm curious to know if you have
any any um background information or
insight into the possibility of um
hydrogen fuel cell vehicles
um and their infrastructure in the
future I know that California already
has that and uh Toyota it has been
selling a vehicle there for at least
three years
um is there any any interest in that
kind of thing
uh Mr chairman if I could uh Elevate if
you could Elevate Becky oler uh and
Catherine beam
um to speaking rules I'd like to have
Becky address that if possible
okay Becky Oller and Kathy beam are now
do a lot of talk
thank you can you hear me yes yes okay
hi I'm Becky older the Des uh so in
response to that we I think that there
is uh definitely going to be a future
for the fuel cell vehicles but probably
more likely in the heavy duty sector uh
where the the long distance travel is
going to be
um hampered by having to have so many
batteries on board we are seeing a lot
of work in both Connecticut and
Massachusetts Connecticut in particular
where they actually have uh companies
that are developing the hydrogen fuel
cell tanks
um so you can imagine it's it's pretty
hard you know hydrogen is the smallest
atom it's pretty hard to keep it
contained so so developing the
appropriate tanks for that is uh has
been quite a science in and of itself
but a lot of work going on in New
England particularly in Massachusetts
and Connecticut Connecticut
thank you
so Mr chairman also if I could just very
quickly add there may be some question
as to why Des is concerned with with
electric vehicles and energy issues and
I think just from an overall perspective
uh we consider electricity to be a very
significant source of pollution but also
it's a significant answer because
changing Vehicles over to
electrification even though that
electricity comes from power plants
they're extremely more efficient and
they use significantly less energy and
uh as the New England grid and the
National Grid gets cleaner and cleaner
over time through the elimination of of
coal uh you know significant use of
natural gas right now and introduction
of more Renewables as time goes on as
that grid cleans up we actually see much
significantly reduced emissions as a
result of the electric vehicles electric
heat pumps in homes Etc so it seems kind
of uh incongruous to say well we want to
go move to more electricity and and then
talk about needing to reduce emissions
from a lectures from the electric sector
but they do go hand in hand and when we
see a significant reduction and uh in
both of those trends for electric uh
Heating and Cooling and vehicle usage
if if I could just add on to that one
little bit it the other issue or the
other sort of benefit of the vehicles
using the electric grid is that as Mike
noted about 80 of charging typically
happens at home and most of that
charging is happening overnight so
you're you're utilizing an existing
infrastructure to at a time when it's
not being used and there is spare energy
available and that way you are spreading
the cost of all of that infrastructure
that has to be there to meet the peak
demands during the daytime hours it's
getting used and paid for overnight
right now it's just sitting there not
being used and nobody you know no income
coming in from it so this the by
spreading out electric use over the the
vehicle sector as well it can
okay thank you representative McGee is
recognized for a question
thank you Mr chairman
um my question I think would also go to
Becky um I was on the admissions
commission uh this past year and
um Chris skoglund did he used I think it
was your slide 14 that showed the
downward trajectory for emissions over
time and it's very impressive trajectory
but one of the points that he made to
our group was that 2021 was the year
where that that lovely trajectory of us
lowering our emissions especially
specifically we're talking CO2 on that
particular uh Commission
that it would it would
um Flatline in 2021 so I wondered if you
could speak about that what he said was
it would Flatline without policy changes
so basically if we stay with the
existing policies that we currently have
as a state he was suggesting that that
trajectory that we were enjoying would
not continue going downward yeah thanks
I'll address that representative McGee
thank you
um and just uh for information again the
slide that we showed today was uh for
our conventional air pollutant standards
um that may have been Co on there not
CO2
um but again uh you're correct uh Chris
did do a presentation for the commission
I was on part of the commission as well
and
um uh we do see that uh New Hampshire uh
emissions and uh and Regional emissions
have declined uh for several years uh as
a result of significant changes in in uh
electricity generation and vehicle
reduction vehicle pollution reduction
but um the we will Plateau we do expect
that those
reductions uh we've gotten what we're
going to get now and we will Plateau in
terms of our levels of emissions uh over
the next 20 to 30 years
um uh absent other policies we've
implemented Reggie the RPS
um again we're getting cleaner Vehicles
we're seeing lower sea level missions
from power plants more Renewables Etc
but those policies are in place and
they've had their effect now and so
we're going to kind of stay flat at this
point absent other other programs and
and reduction uh measures that can be
taken both by our state and on a
thank you can I have a follow-up
follow-up I I guess my question would be
this is my second term on science
technology and energy so I'm still very
much a newbie but my question would be
it's great that you come and show us
your work and that we try to understand
how to integrate that into our work but
I'm wondering what the right balance is
between the state agencies and the
policy makers in terms of trying to
decide
what would be the valuable policies to
put in place because I feel like we're
kind of just putting pins in a you know
where it doesn't seem to be connected
what you guys are saying and what we end
up doing I Wonder has there ever been
um an interplay between the two in terms
of trying to come up with the most
efficient ways for us to meet the goals
well I'll take a crack at that and Craig
might want to might want to jump in too
but um I think probably the place where
there was the most significant interplay
was back in 2009 when we developed the
state's climate action plan and that was
the result of a 29-member bipartisan
commission that was appointed by the
governor at the time
and that plan came up with
um a wide number of recommendations that
were
um you know it was a consensus
plan and there was significant we
received input from all across the state
we held public hearings all across the
state that was a two-year process
and um probably need some updating but
it's still actually a pretty good
document and um there were numerous
legislators involved in that as well as
academics industrial folks
um and so on and so um there was a broad
representation and and uh I think they
came to you know some agreement on to on
what goals New Hampshire ought to adopt
and uh what policies
um we we should be considering and that
plan is uh is still out there it's
available on our website uh but the the
policy action is uh we we that's sort of
in in your court and and we uh we can
only do what
um the legislative you know what if
um actions of the legislature gives us
the authority to uh to take um in
statute and uh and where we do those but
um we certainly think the climate plan
would be a good place to start and you
know maybe dust it off and and look uh
look again but it was a it was a pretty
pretty robust process that produced that
plan
yeah and Mike I think I would just add I
think kind of our role and goal has been
how do we help facilitate this
discussion
um you know we view ourselves as a
resource uh for the legislature to get
information from to fact check things
provide information to
um these are not easy decisions to make
though in terms of where do you go next
how do you get the next round of
reductions
um you know regulating a power plant how
plants are used to being regulated
getting Reggie in it I'm not going to
say it was easy but they've built that
into their operations right they
understand Reggie they it's it's easier
to regulate a power plant than it is to
regulate URI and when we start talking
about people driving habits electric
vehicles that gets much more personal
and I think the choices get harder to
make so we view ourselves as how can we
help you guys make those smart policy
okay next step is representative
Pimentel
thank you Mr chairman I got a question
for uh Mr Wright
um you uh mentioned that
one of the up-and-coming things that's
going to become a bigger issue is a
particulate matter
and I'm curious because a lot of what
we've been discussing this term is
involving uh low-grade
um wood products and how they're being
used for for pellets and Heating
stoves and all this sort of thing and
and of course our biomass plants and I'm
curious
if those things are an issue as far as
particulate matter or are we just
talking about
Your Average
basic wood stove
I I I first I would couch with we have a
saying in the department I am live right
yep uh what is good
as a department we support the
combustion of wood
um
we need I think if we want healthy
forests we need to have healthy
uh actions going on in our forest we
need to have proper logging done enough
for us to maintain our forests
um the biomass plants the large plants
have very significant levels of controls
we may have just lost Craig I I think I
can probably complete his thought that
um uh the activities we
again we we believe that there's a place
for combustion of wood it needs
appropriate controls and
um we we see uh the the issue that we
see coming is that the PM standard as
you saw on our charts that standard is
currently at 35. we see probably going
there's going to be a significant
reduction in that standard coming
sometime in the next uh oh there's Craig
I don't know what happened there sorry
about that go ahead Mike you were
continuing on no I I was just saying
that we see see uh probably a reduction
in the EPA standard coming in the future
and that's going to make
um the the regulation and the the
technology development for new new wood
stoves that are cleaner better
controlled that sort of thing
um the more all the more important so
um we we do see a sort of you know
um combined role of of economy uh Forest
management uh and we work very closely
with uh
um the state Forester and and
um that group in in uh
coming up with the appropriate measures
um here
um but there's there's also a
significant climate role from uh the
standpoint of maintaining forests the
forests are carbon sink and uh if we're
not able to uh properly maintain our
forest and we start losing forested
areas because the wood is not being
harvested appropriately and there's not
not appropriate markets so it all plays
together
um but I think Craig is right there's
certainly going to be a lot of
discussion in this arena in the next uh
next couple of years we have
kind of you know
the old Pogo line we've seen the enemy
and he is us and so we we've got to
figure out how to deal with these
emissions I I figure out a minimum EPA
is going to reevaluate the midnight to
midnight part of the standard
um I know that sounds like technical
jargon but really what again what that
does is it doesn't capture a full event
our lungs don't reset at midnight so you
really need to look at a 24-hour rolling
standard I think if you do that that's
the first thing EPA is going to be
looking at in the near future they did
just re-promagate the standards right at
the end of the last Administration
um I'll be interested to see what the
new Administration does whether they
pick it up
sooner or whether they wait the five
uh it's follow-up
chairman so
um
is is your concern as far as the the
particulate matter
not at the Industrial Level but really
um the wood stove is that
is that how I can interpret what you're
saying
that besides transport which is we've
had some events for example I'm a member
of Memorial Day uh probably five or six
years ago there were Western fires and
they literally put smoke into New
Hampshire
there's nothing we can do about that
obviously
um so that type of event you know that's
Forest management out west that's
nothing we can do about that
um generally what we've seen like in the
Keene area is a very localized impact uh
from home heating
um that's why we went and were able to
successfully do those two wood stove
changeout programs
um like I said what is good it's
renewable it's it's
it's a local resource the money stays in
the local economy it doesn't immediately
leave the state when you you know you
buy a gallon of gasoline that money's
gone small bit goes back to your
retailer but the rest of that money has
gone out of state you know at least wood
is local and I think that's a good thing
so we certainly don't want to be talking
about banning home wood burning or
anything like that we just want it done
as best and as efficiently as cleanly as
possible that's what we need to have in
place we need to continue to work with
EPA and push EPA on making sure they
update those standards for those devices
could I have one more follow-up uh Mr
chairman to our subject uh
the the whole idea of of the of you
replacing the wood stoves I'm just
really curious I I assume there must be
some studies on the particulate matter
in a standard
wood stove with no catalytic converter
no uh uh inducing fan whatever
uh do you know what the difference is in
in real numbers we actually we have a
chart that we can make available to the
committee that talks about different
types of heating devices and we can
certainly provide that to the committee
um but suffice it to say a device
meeting new standards uh probably an
order of magnitude cleaner than devices
that were certified back in 1988.
one of the key issues with wood stoves
is
as you well know they last they
generally last forever you know and the
the prior standard that most of the wood
stoves that are operating today uh was
that standard was issued in 1998 EPA
developed a new standard that took
effect in 2016 there's been some fits
and starts with its application and so
on but
um it's just like heavy duty trucks uh
you know they may last 20 or 30 years so
when you buy one you're stuck with it
for a long time and so that's why we
went with the wood stove replacement was
we were replacing older wood stoves with
newer ones that had more more modern
technology
and I'll just add one closing point in
this I have no interest in regulating on
a house by house basis that's not what
the year division is all about
um we want to work with EPA and we want
to work with the manufacturers so that
the devices that are bought are the
cleanest devices available
we're not talking about being the wood
stove Felicia
I didn't expect that but thank you very
much
it's recognized
thank you Mr chairman
um I'm also curious uh Mr Wright about
your your emphasis on
um the
the particulate matter issue
[Music]
um
is this is your concern mainly drewn
because you think there'll be many more
people using wood burning stoves or or
because obviously um uh you know we we
have a certain population right now
that's using it uh you're regulating it
right now uh are your concerns that the
standards will become more strict or
that more people will use wood and of
course there's there's another issue
that's not directly related that I have
encountered in in my uh very scientific
conferences and that is that
manufacturers are able to make smaller
and smaller particles now that can be a
health hazard when they get into the
body
because they've become so tiny and these
nanoparticles themselves could actually
cause health effects that's not related
to wood burning stoves and I don't think
you're talking about those kind of
things no I'm not I am primarily
concerned with
when we see what's out there for the
science in terms of health impacts of
fine particulate matter it seems likely
that EPA is going to be lowering the
standard in the future so we that's my
primary concern and and if that happens
and we get into a non-attainment
situation because of like wood smoke
from wood burning residential the Clean
Air Act is going to make us not only try
to go after that Source it's going to
make us try to go after industry as well
who are probably not really contributing
so that's really the best course of
action is try to avoid getting there so
you don't have to inadvertently go with
those sources which probably are not
going to help the problem
thank you next step is representative
oxen
thank you very much Mr chair and thank
you gentlemen for taking these questions
uh you've you brought up the climate
action plan that was developed in the
first decade of the 21st century is it
not true that the goals there pretty
much end with 2025 that it's not taking
us into our our next period of advance
now the goals established in the climate
action plan even though there's again
there's no teeth in it it's a plan and
and there it was not adopted into
statute or anything but it did recommend
that New Hampshire adopt goals and those
goals would go to 2050.
okay
um I I believe you're aware and in fact
I know you're aware because I've
discussed it with you that there's um a
bill excuse me Mr chair may I have a
follow-up
yes go ahead thank you
um we we have a climate action plan on
on the table for us to discuss today and
that plan has reduction goals for 20 20
35 25 35 and 50.
um building on and incorporating much of
what was in that original plan
Could you
um advise this committee or do you feel
it's appropriate for you to advise this
committee as to whether you think this
is a matter of some urgency that we
should be taking up or that this is
something that can satisfactorily be um
retained and dealt with at some time in
um yeah I think uh certainly there is
some emergency to uh to the need for
climate planning as to exactly how it's
done and who does it
um that is the the purview of your
committee and the and the legislature
um we uh uh again as I mentioned in my
testimony when I when I testified on
that legislation on again over in the
Senate
um we have extremely limited resources
now compared to what we did back when
when we did worked on the 2009 plan but
um there's a significant has been
significant developments in the body of
science around what types of goals are
necessary and what types of of actions
are necessary
um but I also would put some emphasis on
um trying to understand and better
incorporating Regional approaches
because you know I think it's been made
a point you certainly can say if New
Hampshire does something it's not going
to affect anything
um but again if every state says that
then nothing happens and if every
country says that nothing happens but I
do think that if you look at actions
that states in on in the Northeast
region are taking can we even coordinate
with Canada some through an organization
called any gcp
um we uh
we think that there are joint actions
that can be taken Reggie is a great
example the the Reggie region is
probably the 10th largest economy in the
world
and so
um actions taken on a regional basis are
are very very important for us to
consider participating in and being able
to do our share
um but again what specific policies
um we
you know can make make recommendations
and provide information but um the
policies the policy adoption is uh the
purview of the legislature
yes thank you chairman and thank you for
this wonderful testimony today
um
I don't want to go back to a fine
particle particular um pollution to any
great degree but
uh is this influenced at all I'm part by
ignorance uh due to the environmental
concerns by the uh
growing number of wildfires out in our
western part of our country they
contribute significantly to our uh
um fine particular pollution they
certainly can in certain circumstances I
mean as I mentioned there was the
Memorial Day event a number of years ago
where literally those were either
Canadian wildfires or Western wildfires
there was also if you recall Western
fires this year
um that actually came very close to
impacting our air shed here it actually
got up high enough where literally it
went over us
if it had stuck at the ground level it
certainly would have impacted us
we we certainly do see more frequently
though uh impacts from uh from Canada
um you know as you if you watch uh your
your weather each night you see the uh
air masses coming in from from uh from
Canada a lot and uh coming down sweeping
across New York and and when there are
wildfires up there which there
frequently are um we we see significant
impacts from those
thank you for that disquieting answer I
thank you uh representative samsich is
recognized for a question
thank you Mr chairman uh this is not so
much a question but maybe just uh uh
asking you to comment on this uh you
know not too long ago in the 80s
we had the whole issue of acid rain in
New Hampshire and how that was a big
focus of the Clean Air Act and could you
comment on how how much how effective
that was in reducing that problem here
in New Hampshire with the acidic levels
in in our lakes and and various areas
um people sometimes forget these kind of
efforts when they fade from the
headlines but I think that was a success
story am I not mistaken I I would
venture to say that the acid rain
program in the United States was one of
the most successful environmental
programs ever to come out of Congress
um it was literally a cap and trade type
program
um that gave you know essentially gave
allowances to companies and allowed
people to find the most cost effective
reductions
um in their in Sulfur emissions and to
some degree nitrogen emissions but it's
been primarily sulfur it has been widely
successful
we have seen probably and I have a chat
on this that I could provide the
committee as well uh Des actually
believed it enough since the 1970s has
been tracking the pH of rain water on
our own building here and we actually
compiled that data a couple years ago
and put out a report on that and some
graphs on that we can make that
available but it was tremendously
successful uh you could see it in the
data you can see the Improvement in the
pH of the rain water we're still not
back to Natural levels but we're getting
there you're never going to get to a
neutral level because you get carbon
dioxide in the atmosphere and that forms
a carbon acid as well as sulfuric acid
so but why these successful we can
certainly provide some information to
the committee
um uh let's see Representatives partial
you still have your hand up or okay
[Music]
looks like no one else has a question so
at this point we'll say to like it once
I was going to do earlier when I
tried to ask my question really I
couldn't ask it oh representative Renner
um when he's touched on the pfast
um
do you guys do anything in your division
when it comes to this proposed uh
landfill it's proposed to the North
country do you guys do anything when you
mention surface water or pfas I was just
curious yeah absolutely we uh uh we
regulate air emissions from landfills
and so any landfill needs to get a
permit from us
um pfest is not generally thought to be
a significant air emissions problem from
from landfills there's some research
going on right now
um and uh but they are required to get a
permit from us for for their air
emissions as well as a solid waste
permit those are two individual permits
they're not intertwined
um and they uh any facility must get
both
um we have had some questions because
and I don't know Kathy did you is there
anything you wanted to add on uh
landfill emissions related to pfest
no I think you covered it there's been
some studies that are going on about
landfill gas but nothing consistent yeah
but they're certainly there may be
um
you know leachate concerns and uh that
would be the purview of the waste
Division and their uh their Solid Waste
permit and groundwater requirements
um so two different two different media
but uh
um so yes concerns have been raised and
we we certainly are looking at that Mike
and I'll just add just uh for the
representatives information that to date
the year division has not received an
application for that project so we
officially have nothing in front of us
at this point in time as the air
division there are other applications
for the solid waste permit or aot
permits but not the air division at this
point well thank you because that was
going to be my question
including the town it's going in and
I've stayed try to stay neutral but you
know I'm trying to gather information
there's all the I actually got three
emails while you guys were giving the
presentation on this landfill so so the
big one proposed by Casello so uh
representative I will just add that when
when and if we receive an application
um there will certainly there's
certainly a public process that goes on
with the issuance of an air permit and
of course we would follow that procedure
as required by the statute so
okay thank you the facility must have
both of those permits in hand before
they can begin Construction
thank you representative Bernardi is
recognized for a question will your
slide Global uh consent for the
committee
yes we can do that
well seeing no other questions I would
that is being
zoler for being here today and making
this excellent presentation to the
committee thank you for your hard work
and your service to the state and I'm
sure we'll see you again at Future
committee meetings
thank you Mr chairman we greatly
appreciate the time that we spent with
you today we think this is always an
effort well spent
as you so thanks to you again
all right it is 2 27 we'll take a five
minute bio break and then we will come
back and resume our full committee work
session
foreign
thank you
okay we're back
the people now resume our full committee
work session
a variety of bills and I will open the
floor for discussion on any bills that
five
so the bills we could discuss would be
106 148 167 213
172 or 394.
representative
to me highly
return to the ones that flow right out
of the presentation we just had
172 is on the climate plan and the um
the carbon pricing I think we could
probably get through in about 60 seconds
and uh then as I mentioned earlier this
morning I'm hoping that we can
um act with some emergency on 153 which
is the Broadband bill
foreign
to prioritize my own bills but I'd just
uh as far as I'm concerned you can take
right off with either one of those
builds if you'd like
um I I think there's some other hands up
before I I mean I'd love to do that but
maybe we need to hear from somebody else
about their priorities
okay representative samsich
oh what
I don't have any priority I think uh we
shouldn't waste any time if someone
wants to say something they should say
it so Lee you might as well go ahead as
far as I'm concerned
okay
hand up for 106 before we cut away to
lunch so I was hoping that we could
conclude the conversation there because
I I did have a point I was trying to
make before we went to break but
um but it's it's okay with me however we
want to attack
the afternoon's work I'm not adamant
about it I just think we were embroiled
in a discussion but we I don't think we
were quite done with it so
um so I guess that would be the way I
would approach it is to finish that and
then go on but
um
thumbs down whether you think we should
continue oh thank you very much for
throwing it back to me um I also had my
hand up at the end of 106. so maybe if
we could do one one of your um you know
time limited you know finish up 106 in
the next 10 minutes and then move on to
the others
sounds good to me so representative
McGee you're recognized thank you very
much and I'll take my hand down now so I
don't keep it up there yeah the uh I
think the the point that I wanted to
make or the or for us to consider is
again on the arbitrariness of picking
something so that we can pass the bill
because I think representative Lang made
it really clear that originally when the
bill came to me and I asked to be on it
with him
um it didn't have a cap and it was based
on the fact that we were trying to solve
something for municipalities and my
understanding is that there are a number
of projects pending especially in some
of the larger cities around the state
that would be going up to that cap and
another
point to make for folks who might not be
familiar with it is that representative
Lang made the point that municipalities
have to use a hundred percent of the
energy right so if they if they only use
90 of the energy
um and they don't go to the full hundred
percent
um
then they're you know they're not making
back what they thought they were going
to make but if they but they can't net
meter
how am I going to explain this
if
you can't net meter for uh
I lost my point
I lost my point I had it written down
but I don't have it anymore because it
was was in here so
you go on and I'll find my point and
I'll come back in
you had your hand up too right okay
representative oxygen I'll find my point
and I'll get back to you thank you very
much
um I think the point that Kat was trying
to make was that they don't they're not
allowed to sell their excess and make
money off of it they're held to that
that the amount that their own
consumption so that there isn't an issue
of cost shifting with with these um
larger uh facilities the point that I
wanted to make earlier today was that
they come in in discreet bits you can't
just say oh well you can do up to two
megawatts if if um Nashville would say
is already at one megawatts and they
want to bring in there and what is it
called the nine Mills
um mines facility that's a three
megawatt entity you can't have part of
it in and part of it out so if you have
a two megawatt cap you're saying nope
you you're you're completely not being
helped by the bill if it has this um
artificial invitation of the two
megawatt cap and we know that there are
five megawatt facilities that Manchester
is consider during conference
considering you know these these
structures are really only cost
effective if they reach those kinds of
scale and again it benefits everyone if
these municipalities are enabled to go
forward if they're artificially
constrained it's not going to be
protecting somebody's current
electricity bill it's going to mean that
we're not producing energy locally so
we're going to be buying it from out of
state we're going to be sending our
money and that was Economic Development
dollars out of state this is a good bill
as it stands we don't need this
amendment and and may I also raise the
point that I believe there's another
amendment pending on this bill that was
being brought in by representative
McWilliams which we should probably also
have an opportunity to discuss before we
leave this issue
yes thank you representative
representative McWilliams Amendment and
I was going to call on her to discuss
her Amendment but she doesn't appear to
be here so I will go back to
the point that I was planning to make
which I think it wasn't understood by me
and I think most people are not aware
is that net metering is not possible for
a fraction of what a generator generates
so if a generator is over one megawatt
if they're 1.2 megawatt and the ceiling
is one megawatt they're not allowed to
do it at all so if you have generators
who have
three megawatts and you raise the
ceiling to two megawatts they can't net
meter for a fraction of what they
generate so they're prohibited if you
don't raise the cap all the way then
then folks that have two or three or
four megawatts will they will not be
able to participate because you can't
you can't uh you can't net meter for a
fraction of your generation it has to be
the generation cap has to include how
much generation you produce does that
make sense I don't know if I'm
explaining it right but I I wasn't
really aware of that so what it means is
that if you raise the cap to two and
there's a hydro plant that generates
three they won't be able to participate
because they can't have only two
two megawatts of their three total
generation participate they have to
either participate or not participate so
you're excluding those folks who are
over two megawatts which is another
reason why that arbitrary Choice doesn't
make it
an advancement it doesn't make it better
that Two Is Better Than One it still
leaves out a bunch of people who are
trying to participate so I guess that's
the point I was trying to make
does it make does that make sense
because I I was not a point that I was
aware of
yes it made sense thank you we
appreciate that all right thanks
it's always confused me about Municipal
municipalities thinking about building
renewable energy facilities
is why they can't figure out how to
justify the cost
so for example if the city of Concord
wants to build a
three megawatt
solar facility and it has the land on
which to build such a facility
then
they can lower their
Municipal electric load by three
megawatts
continuously why isn't that sufficient
to allow them to go forward with the
projects
they're paying
uh
70 or 80 dollars a megawatt for a
megawatt hour for their electricity it
seemed to me like the savings would be
tremendous
on a yearly basis and therefore I can
understand why
municipalities don't feel they can go
forward without
net metering
I think a lot of them have I think I
ier I know it's rhetorical or it's out
to everyone but people who want to speak
so
thank you Mr chairman um yeah I just
wanted to uh
put in a plug for the forest industry
and uh HB 213
um the the idea of eliminating thermal
energy Rex isn't is a is a really bad
idea
um and I I know that we're thinking of
retaining it anyway but I just want to
underscore how important contribution it
makes right now in our state this is a
local energy source
um they're they're finding ways of
partnering with various uh entities in
in nearby and
um I I think we we heard
um various stories from
um Berlin for example what they're
trying to do with their biomass plant
um so I think we we definitely should
make sure that whatever we can generate
in our state in the way of thermal
energy uh from wood products or other
sources for that matter we should really
make that a priority to support So
eliminating it would be really a a step
in the wrong direction I just wanted to
mention that because we're we're not
talking just about the energy they
create they create a whole host of
um secondary effects in the economy in
the environment in tourism uh indirectly
as well as employment so
um wants to keep that in mind when we're
talking about those issues thank you
thank you representative
representative before we I recognize the
next speaker I want to point out that
representative Thomas who unfortunately
is not here meant to leave for a
important business activity
he hadn't intended to submit this
session a bill to create a study
commission to
find alternative uses of low-grade wood
in New Hampshire
there is a
Consortium of North Country
individuals in Vermont
New York Maine
who are looking into this issue right
now and New Hampshire would like to join
that effort
and a study Commission
established by this legislature
could lend Credence to that desire
and enable the state to apply for some
federal funds so that we could join that
that effort
and so
representative Thomas wanted to to
introduce this legislation to create
this study commission but
with the new system we have of using ask
OLS to create
bills
the
the legislation essentially got lost in
his inbox and even though the bill was
actually written by OLS he didn't uh
realize that it was in his inbox it got
buried under a bunch of other emails and
so he never approved
the LSR and so it got
um
killed by OLS
one of the advantages for retaining SB
hb213 would be that we could bring back
or bring forward that study Commission
and
maybe turn HP 213 into a study
commission bill
so that we could actually
speed up the process of developing
a study of how to use New Hampshire
low-grade Forest Products more
efficiently
find markets for them so uh for that
reason alone I think we should retain
between 213. excuse me Mr chair just a
clarification I believe that you told us
that we were not able to pass any kind
of study committee or study commission
that none of that would be passed in our
committee would that not circumvent that
idea if we merged it with a retained
Bill a little next session no because
we're allowed to retain bills and bring
them forward early next year so if we
see in 213 and then amend it to create
the study commission we can bring that
forward in January of next year
well I think it's a great idea I solely
support that idea so thank you yeah okay
thank you
I'm going to go back from 213 to 106
because the question that you put out
there about why towns I started to
answer that and I just wanted to
add to the conversation while we're
having the work meeting that
um I think the premise behind having a
net metering available
is to incent us to have more control
over local production generation of
energy
and so it is an incentive uh right for
investment it's not that cities and
towns won't invest or that they haven't
invested or that they won't continue to
invest but what it does is like every
other clean energy investment it gives
the return on investments
um value uh to make the investment so it
it it's uh it's an accelerator if you
will and I think that that's how Most
states use net metering
um and so for my town in particular I
know that we have problems with Peak
because schools use their energy in the
middle of the day so even though they
put solar panels on our elementary
school in the primary school
they weren't seeing the return on
investment that they had expected
because they don't qualify above that
one megawatt for net metering rates and
so there's a there's an economics to the
Investments that we don't really discuss
here I think sufficiently for us to be
making good and logical decisions around
how it's going to affect Downstream
whether it's municipalities or
businesses but that's the reason it's
not that that towns don't have the money
in you know in all cases they don't but
a lot of towns are making uh room for in
their budgets to make the Investments
but they're not going to get return on
that investment uh as rapidly if we
don't have policies that keep up with
the fact that we're I thought as a
legislator supposed to be supporting the
idea of having more control and lowering
our load demand basically as a state
which will lower rates for everybody
that's that's my understanding of what
the
what um
you know what's basically driving the
thank you Mr chairman I going back on to
uh 213 I think it's a great idea to have
a study committee and uh
my only issue is maybe a procedural one
I'm not sure if we
if we retain this bill how soon would be
we be able to to change it into a study
committee bill
and
is that all we would do I I guess
can you have a study committee bill that
would also take away uh T-Rex for
instance
uh no
to that last question the answer would
be no
if we changed this to a study committee
it would essentially replace the
that would probably be the amendment
that would be offered
the way retained bills work
is once you vote to retain a bill
you can no longer take any action on it
before the end of the current
calendar session
so that would mean that we couldn't take
this calendar session ends which ends on
roughly July about June 30th
then you're required to come back in the
fall
or actually we could actually start soon
with that but by the by the first of
November or the first of December I
forget which you have to make a decision
what you want to do with a retaining
bill
either IPL it
or you pass it or where you pass it as
Amendment so what would happen with
these retained bills is we'll come back
in the fall we'll start having meetings
and I don't know maybe
late September
through October
you'll have work sessions similar to the
one we're having now
and then we'll actually
end up having additional exec sessions
in which we decide whether to itl or
pass the bills that we have retained
that's how it'll work and during the
course of that process Amendments of
course are permissible so if we wanted
to to retain 213 now and then amend it
later we could do that you could do that
with any of the bills
that's how the process will work
so just to follow up Mr chair so would
we be able to vote on that amended bill
in the fall and actually have it go to
uh a legislative session or does it have
to wait until the following year
yes we would be able to vote on it in
the fall just in committee
and then our recommendation would go to
the house the house doesn't start
meeting again until after January 1st
okay once the house starts to meet again
then it would take up all the bills that
have been reported out of committee at
that point so I expect that next January
we'll start having house sessions fairly
soon after the beginning of the year
because there will be a whole bunch of
pertained bills that will have been
reported out of committee and we'll be
having house sessions to decide what to
do with them
still so could I follow up on that Mr
chair because I still haven't gotten my
question completely answered okay one
quick follow-up and then we've got two
other hands so my question is
uh aren't we allowed to to uh submit new
lsrs in the fall to be taken up
next year yes we are absolutely and so
the question is what the the reason I
may bring this up I think that 213 is
like this
this Hammer that is kind of sitting over
the the
um
the economy as far as uh
uh increasing the amount of uh
uh
places that are going to want to install
um biomass
uh heating systems that sort of thing
they're they're less likely to decide to
do it waiting to for the outcome of this
particular piece of legislation so
if we're only going to change it into a
study committee
bill
we can do that in the fall anyway it it
doesn't have to be
uh an amendment to an existing bill
you are correct at least submit a new
LSR or we could create
an amendment to an existing Bill the
advantage of doing the latter is it goes
to the floor much sooner
if we submit an LSR
in the fall what happens is it gets
converted into a bill then it gets
assigned to a committee it goes through
the full committee process
it goes to the house floor gets voted on
if it's voted on affirmatively it goes
to the Senate the Senate does the whole
thing all over again so the soonest this
bill could could hit the the governor's
desk would be like August if it's an LSR
but if we create a study committee bill
it will fall from an existing bill they
could hit the governor's desk as early
as February or March
so there is an advantage to converting
an existing bill
rather than submitting the new LSR
it doesn't work either way but we speed
up the process a little bit by
submitting an LSR chair recognizes
representative murder he just he just
kind of answered it I was antsy trying
to get out of it we did a bill a couple
years ago that chairman voles worked
very very hard on it was uh Bill 700 we
put 13 hours of testimony just in the
month of October and at the end of it we
made it a study bill
we got it they worked on it we got it
done and it became a law that the
following year it was an incredible
accomplishment people were way over here
people way over there and when the study
Community get together
they put this together and we got it
done quicker than if we did the process
of refiling the bill so uh to the
Chairman's Point uh it does work we did
it in this committee on a couple of
bills and it does work
so just leave it at that because that
was a huge project across the state huge
projects that was the uh utility uh
assessment methodology
yeah thank you Mr chairman I kind of
wanted to follow up on your your own
comments uh regarding uh why why
financially uh some of these projects
can't just be built by municipalities
with the possible benefits that they
would achieve and I think somebody I
think it was uh representative oxenham
mentioned the financial aspect
I I would suggest maybe that we might
want to have when we have an opportunity
we won't might want to bring in some
people some Finance people to tell us
people who are not necessarily in the in
the business of selling us anything but
to go through the financing of how
renewable energy projects are financed
both for private individuals as well as
for municipalities and businesses how
does the financing come together where
does Net metering play a role uh the
power purchase agreements when is that a
good idea when does it not work uh that
would be really useful for us to look at
the framework of the financial part of
this and I think some of the questions
we have may be answered by those by such
a session that we would get a little bit
of renewable energy economics 101 about
how this stuff all works because it's
pretty complicated intricate and
sometimes not not applicable everywhere
so I'm just making that suggestion
I like it it's a good idea we'll try to
put that together maybe you and I can
work on that together Mr chairman uh
representative Flint is recognized for a
comment yes thank you I'm trying to
understand the comments I hear about
local
my current debate locally it's a Nissan
Rogue Japanese uh name but it's made in
Smyrna Tennessee
my clothes aren't me
my house has been made locally it's
manufactured home it's somehow local for
utility that for a plant is supposed to
be magic every plant that was built
locally been fought by crazy like a
Seabrook in the in the gas that the
combined cycle put into London there a
good spot like hell uh Antrim plate the
winds got fought like that what's so
look magic about local I don't know how
many local if it's economic but if it's
not a rate pays Pockets I have a problem
representative Bernardi is recognized
for a comment
piggybacking off of uh whatever it is
comments about
costs and uh
renewable 101 I think the other side of
the equation is what we've talked about
these cost shifting and the cost
shifting issue is because Renewables are
not reliable the hydro doesn't always
run
the sun doesn't always shine
the wind doesn't always blow there needs
to be a reliable Baseline
system that exists because that cost and
if that cost is just deferred to the
utility customer and not those that
benefit from the uh Renewables there is
a cost shifting there so let's
understand economics to the back side of
representative Bernardi for his point I
think the I think the point I heard
there was that capacity is different for
a base load Source versus a renewable
source which is more of an intermittent
which is true and actually Hydro does
run all the time they basically shut it
off when they don't want it running but
water runs but I guess if it's low maybe
it doesn't depends on the particular
Hydro Source but Hydro tends to be uh
you know a higher capacity Factor than
some of the others that isn't the source
of that that's why we do need a finance
101 I think
um that capacity Factor uh does
does impact cost
but it doesn't cause cost shifting so
back to the point that representative
Platt made
which is that
um what's so great about local the idea
is that if we are able to generate power
in our own towns
instead of importing it over the
transmission system and paying fossil
fuel companies who are all located out
of state then we keep the we keep the
energy dollars in the state right so it
generates into our economy it doesn't
leave
um and also if we generate energy near
to the source where it's being used
we eliminate the cost of the
transmission and we also lower the load
what is needed so it lowers the cost of
what we import uh in terms of fossil
fuels through pipelines or other means
so as we lower our load our demand
uh costs go down so we what we are
trying to do is lower our costs by
producing more of the energy ourselves
that's the argument there's no shifting
to anybody if if I put up a solar panel
and I no longer need a bunch of Watts
that I use throughout the year those
kilowatts just don't get bought uh it
doesn't mean that somebody else's
bills go up they still use what they use
so it's we're lowering
our usage we're not
we're not shifting what I use to what
you use it that doesn't happen so it's
that's why we need somebody to come in
and explain it so that we all understand
the same thing because we have an
impression of how it works but it's not
necessarily accurate and we owe it to
the people that we serve to get it right
I think
um and and the reason I had my hand up
was because I thought that
representative pimental made a really
good point which is that we have heard
from a number of people in the timber
industry in the forestry industry saying
that this is a you know a job killer for
them
uh 213 is is is a significant impact to
them whether they can keep their doors
open keep their people employed and I
think we should we should put that we
should factor that into whether or not
this gets it yelled or gets held like a
sort of Damocles over everybody's head
while they wait to see which way we fall
on it
um I think it's a really relevant point
it this is a huge sector of the New
Hampshire economy
that we are sort of toying with by
leaving it out there and having people
not know whether we're going to be
closing their doors for them
I just wanted to reiterate that I
thought that that was something we
should be considering again economics
and I was the one that brought up the
economics
okay representative Bernardi is
recognized
again thank you
I
I expect this great I do believe that
economics and caution needs to be
considered uh there are many Hydro small
to male hydrogens that running spring
when Melba happens and the waters are
high from the winter uh melt but in the
fall
they're not running at all after a nice
dry summer
um
likewise other uh solar or whatever do
not work all the time so the utilities
have to have enough capacity to cover
anytime those Renewables aren't there
who pays for that that economic question
needs to be on the table as well and if
support of Renewables and whatnot divert
those costs to one sector versus another
that's a legitimate question that needs
thank you Mr chairman uh I agree with
representative Bernardi's comment that
those those are issues that really we
need to look at
clear-eyed financially
however I want to point out to him that
economics doesn't seem to work always
the way we expect it many of us on this
committee went to visit the gas-fired
power plant in Londonderry
and if some of you were there and
remember I asked them how often do you
run
and they said 28 percent of the time
well a capacity Factor 20 28 is not too
impressive
and they still manage sustain business
even though they run only 28 percent of
the time so this idea that under other
sources are intermittent well here's a
source that is
um has chosen to be intermittent because
they want to play the game of when they
can make the most money and lo and
behold they're still in business and
doing well so it doesn't always work the
way we think it works and now you can
add to that factor the the issue of
battery storage which will make some of
these sources more flexible including
the hydros that they can use that energy
when that when they can get the best
price for instead of using it constantly
because they have no way of of selling
that power at the time they're
generating it so all those things have
to be taken into consideration that's
why I think the economics picture is not
at all as clear as people think uh you
know this is not a real Market Market
driven business and and it's a highly
regulated business so um it would be
good to know the rules of the road when
representative substance you make a good
point the Calpine plant in Londonderry
of course can run anytime
the reason it only runs 28 of the time
is because that's how often ISO New
England asks it to run
because the price that it bit into the
uh Market
is such that ISO New England calls on
other cheaper generators before it calls
on the Latin the gas plant in
Londonderry
but it's available all the time you're
not run all the time but it's available
all the time and I think representative
Bernardi's point was that
there are uh problems with Renewables in
that they're not always available and
that is an issue they're not
dispatchable gas plants are dispatched
so that's important
uh representative Krishan love to have
you join this conversation you're next
I'm just asking if we have anything on
deck in terms of thinking about the
reliability of Renewables about energy
storage and ways that we could invest in
that
um to sort of mitigate that problem as
well as you know keeping a variety of
I'm not sure I understand your question
but
it sounds like the batteries are we
doing anything with batteries
for storing overage we have added
storage to Statute in several different
places to make sure that battery storage
as it becomes economically feasible it's
recognized as a viable source of energy
I would say that at this point in time
it's economic feasibility is still
fairly low
representative partial or did you have
another comment you wanted to make
creation
okay representative I yeah I guess I
just wanted to clarify that I see
storage as one potential way to to
mitigate some of those Ebbs and flows in
production as well as demand so that's
another way to approach it in my opinion
yes it's been fairly well recognized for
a long time that battery storage has
potential
understand
that potentially representative murder
yes the owners of these biomass plants I
know that we've gone Rounds Around for
Lots quite a few years they sold they've
sold off four of them before that have
been bought by new investors now how
these plants work to sustain right now
without even firing up they're getting a
hundred thousand dollars a month finally
sort of New England as long as they can
be on within 24 hours so these guys
bought these plants and are getting 1.2
million dollars just to have the plants
sit there now if they the one in
Bethlehem wasn't even able to be turned
on when it needed to be turned on
because they weren't doing that so
they'll take a hit for a hundred
thousand dollars less
I've talked to the employers and the new
owners and there's one in Whitefield and
they're all playing the game so as much
as they're crying some of these about
the new buyer or when it's not we have
one exception we have a plant in
Bridgewater where Mr O'Leary has came
and spoke to us many times he's very
honest and straightforward he runs all
the time but these other plants are
really playing a game and it's similar
to what goes on down in Londonderry
because they get that money from isil no
matter whether they're on or off it's an
on-demand payment they get so uh that's
something I don't think that we know as
a committee and I was kind of shocked
because one of my best friends was the
operator definitely how many left there
what the new owner said uh he says
they're just abusing it still so um as
much as they ask for all these things I
do think the thermal credits are very
important to this all the small projects
and the Investments we have in the North
Country all our hospitals and schools
are running off them with with money
public money to pay for these to keep
them going it's not no private money
involved with all those projects so uh I
actually wrote a couple of grants for
these uh projects so
um but this the biomass thing I think is
very interesting I don't know if we knew
that in that committee the big dick
getting 1.2 million for just sitting
there so
well we did know that or at least
some of us did it those of us who have
studied the iso the structure of the iso
maybe the way the market works is
everybody who wants to supply power to
ISM to England
it's in
solar and wind typically been in at zero
dollars
gas plants typically bid in at
a dollar or two or three or four per
megawatt
and then uh and you know with nuclear
plants and then coal and oil plants will
so then when I asked ISO in New England
goes to provide Power on any given day
they always take the lowest bid power
first
and they add that to the grid and if
that satisfies the load then that's as
far as they go
if it doesn't satisfy the the load then
they go to the next tier and they add
those generators
and the price that gets paid to
everybody is the price that gets paid to
the last generator in
it and so on and so forth it keeps going
up and up two weeks ago everybody that's
how we got to the point last month and
it was so cold and everything turned on
where the coal plant over in Beau was
operating every single day but they bid
in pretty high you know like
yeah
so the uh the price of
electricity the iOS ISO New England
region was very very high as a result
and uh
you know Beau has run for pretty much
every day out of the last six weeks so
they're not only earning their thousand
hundred thousand dollars a month in
capacity payments although for Bo I
think it's worth it
money for the power that they actually
generate so right now there's they're
raking in a lot of money that's how the
market was designed and that's how it
works
can it works that way for the biomass
plants too they can either generate
power and earn money from the generation
of power plus they can sell the wrecks
for the power they do generate
or they can just collect their capacity
sit plant sit there and
it's basically so either way it works
okay next step is uh representative
McGee
I'm listening to all of the information
that you're putting out and that others
have talked about and it just reinforces
for me the complexity of the decisions
that we make in terms of policy because
what I had written down was
understanding the scale of the solutions
we're proposing and I got that from
listening
um to representative creation talking
about battery storage because if we
could use battery storage to
handle our Peaks and all that if we had
that capacity at this point there'd be
more investment there it is a solution
but it is a small scale solution and we
don't talk about any of the solutions at
scale we don't have an overall plan
um reliability is what isil is
responsible for and we do to
um representative Bernardi's point we we
require base load to meet that
reliability requirement
so you need base load and one of the
problems with the nuclear plant which
isn't putting carbon in the air is that
it hasn't been able to load follow in
the current configuration that it's in
so
we have all of these different competing
factors the capacity Factor the load
following Factor the cost factor and
another thing that used to be discussed
a lot in New Hampshire policy was fuel
diversity as being a way of keeping
competition so that no single type of
fuel source
could have a monopoly and be able to
charge whatever it wanted so the the
markets around ISO are still providing
that diversity right because they they
go out and they look at where they can
get the cheapest
um and part of the reason you have to
keep those idle biomass plants to the
side is that you need pink or plants and
it's probably cheaper to have them there
not doing anything and at least know
that you have that capability but that's
the stuff we have to understand before
we undertake policies that just throw it
all up in the air because it's uh a lot
more complicated than just you know this
is cost shifting like that's not that's
not all that's happening and the and the
other question I think that would be
really important for us to address when
we take a look at the suite of policies
that come across our committee's desk is
really what are we trying to achieve
what are we trying to solve if anything
with the policies that we're putting
forward this year and I just feel for me
it's we're really lacking in that
department in terms of being able to
have conversations around what does it
do we want to get done
um so I I feel bad that we
don't do that because no matter what we
bring up there's always a counter
argument there's always another piece
because it's complicated but if we had
some clear objectives we probably would
have a better ability to talk about them
in a confined way and get the answers
that we need
so I I just wish we could do more of
that I'm really glad we're having a work
session today so we can talk
because we have
we have a committee and to just
everybody to just go home and make up
what they think is hard
because we have a lot of different
experience here and it's very helpful to
hear from other people
so that's all I just wrote down a bunch
of different things because people are
covering it's like Bing Bing Bing you
know and all of it's relevant but we
have to focus on whatever it is we're
trying to do before we can have the
answers about which is the right way to
go
so the complexity that we that you
address
helps to explain why ISO New England
employs over 500 people right yeah
up next is representative partial
thank you chairman VOS
um
I was going to speak about diversity as
well and I said thanks uh to
representative McGee for touching on
that I really see it as our future and
um
with diversity we're one of the
possibility of keeping more of our
production right here in New Hampshire
rather than relying on other states
and I think that will probably be uh key
for our economic development in the
future as well
and it's it's composition is good I I
would hate to see anything at biomass
solar any nuclear I would hate to see
any of these i options being taken off
the table if it means that we're going
to uh
allow other companies to have more
Monopoly so I see it's working in um in
our in the consumer is good in that way
um
and um
oh and uh
also being reliant on one type of fuel
also it's concern of mine or we saw what
happened in Texas we said like uh when
there are gas uh facilities could not
run I don't think we're facing that
exact situation here but I would hate us
moving down the road towards that
situation
I was mentioning that sun doesn't always
shine or you know some of these
Renewables are not always uh
uh
available at peak times
but I like to point out the vowels are
you the gas market right now I've seen
gas in my own lifetime go from 27 cents
a gallon to uh I don't know what it is
now I don't drive anymore I don't go to
the gas station my electric car but I
know that I mean we're talking about uh
limited product it's only going to
become more volatile as uh as we went
out of oil I I would rather excuse
looking towards the future
and last I would like to thank all
everybody here for making this such an
educational day in particular
representative Harrington I would love
to hear more about uh
um your view on the biomass
um
uh plants I have one question for you if
I could
are they right now currently buying soft
wood products to fire these plants
because if they're not running they
don't need to buy soft wood I gather so
there's already well I don't know I I do
okay
if Mr Harrington wanted to respond to
that first I'm fine with that
representative Arrington
did you want to respond to
representative Harrington do you want to
I'm guessing he actually all right
shower sometime
all right so
um a couple of things number one uh
getting back uh to HB 213 I'm just
wondering if maybe uh representative
Thomas could uh
dig into his uh emails and find that LSR
and uh get it over to lob uh OLS to get
it written into a an amendment and we
can
take up 213
and get an amendment done which will
change it to whatever
uh we're talking about a study committee
and then we can go ahead and um
uh retain it at that point and that way
we would not have this whole issue of
um
of the of the uh
biomass and the uh wood pulp industry
the timber industry wondering uh what's
hap gonna happen next so so I have a
little bit more uh
uh they could relax a little bit more
through the next year
um that's my first suggestion and then
the other suggestion I think I wanted to
bring up was that we've been talking
about how
um
renewable energies
are not always on
and
um therefore they're not any good
and yet we did have a bill at HP 407
where we were going to uh allow
up to five megawatt storage facilities
to be uh limited producers
and uh that was itl'd
10 11 to 10 so I mean we have an
opportunity to make Renewables a little
more
um
dependable and we kind of
didn't do anything about it
that's all thanks
okay thank you uh Representatives
recognized
thank you Mr chairman uh just a question
to refer everybody who is here right now
I two days ago I heard from a friend of
mine uh the the
um message that he had heard that
because of the uh the disaster in Texas
with their storm and their energy system
that as the result of that propane
prices have spiked and for a lot of
people in the North Country here in New
Hampshire that are heating their homes
with propane they may be facing very
high prices shortly does anyone know
my representative cambrose is recognized
yes I can tell you uh personally that my
propane bills have gone up in the last
three months from 140 a gallon to 180
000.
mine just went from
150 around 150 to 258 a gallon my last
paid my last shipment they went up over
a dollar a gallon
anybody else have a comment
I have a propane contract I pay a dollar
69 a gallon a month a year cash deal
just because
uh
yes uh representative shops that you are
natural gas prices all over the Eastern
Seaboard half gone up as a result of the
situation in Texas
yeah
some of their welds stopped producing
because some of the pumps and stuff
another facilities froze up so
you know it's classic supply and demand
the demand is still there but the supply
has gone down so the price goes
representative Bernardi
do you have a comment
would only had that I think uh shutting
down the pipeline
project added
a futuristic
at the angeries of weather and they will
always plague us in one way or another
representative play
yeah the both Texas
they didn't have a capacity Market
strictly relying on an energy market so
Energy prices went sky-highed at seven
dollars a kilowatt hour didn't get 17
000 bills
and because they had no capacity Market
there was no incentive for people to be
to be on standby with with actual people
on the planet and those are the level of
persuasion will point to the gas plant
it's also a conservative of the
persuasive the point of the windmills
were all correct the windmills weren't
coated with blood the blades were
and
what they have to provide for
reliability
thank you uh representative man did you
have your hand up yeah yes I did a
second ago I just was going to uh
mention that a lot of us are being new
haven't maybe seen the Northfield
Massachusetts
um pump storage where they have a lake
high up on a hill
and they when electricity is cheap they
Pump It Up from the Connecticut River
and fill the lake and when it's high
priced they generate electricity pouring
the water back down
and that seems to be a model for the uh
that we could just think of that model
and use you know the biomass plants as
the lake
you know something you can call on when
you need it
essentially
okay good idea representative oxygen
just a mental model
been really excellent that we have an
opportunity to talk about some of the
things that we know a little about and
some of the things that some people know
more about and but we have
an issue before us on the table today
which is a number of bills that that are
awaiting action
um I I think that representative
pimentel's point about 213 is very well
taken if we could
um agree that you know we would like to
see a study committee coming out of this
and take that sort of Damocles off
businesses across the state have told
the legislature over and over again that
they don't like surprises they don't
like changes they need an investment
climate that they have some stability
and they can forecast developments they
think five six ten years out in terms of
Investments this it's really
harmful for our constituents to leave
this um hanging out there if it's not
something that we think we're going to
proceed with so if if we could get
accomplished one thing this afternoon uh
to to
maybe have a straw poll to see whether
we should ask OLS for for that um
amendment I think that could be very
useful
okay
the sermons were already there
representative murder you think Mr the
thoroughs are already there I mean this
bill is to take away the thermals can
already do that so I mean we're not you
know we're not you know if nothing
happens with this bill it's not going to
change the climate out there it's it is
what it is right now I mean is there
fear that we might lower them I think
we're pretty much a consensus that's not
going to happen so I mean that's why we
want to put together a study committee
to make sure we get it right
follow up
audition we should make that known and
not leave the public and these
businesses feeling like at any moment
the road could be dragged out from under
them so if if we could make that bill
into an amendment and have it replace
the bill and we could vote that through
on Monday that that would be a
significant accomplishment for um a
major sector of the New Hampshire
economy
it's a great idea but we couldn't do it
on Monday because we'd have to have a
public hearing on that Amendment because
it's a complete replacement of the bill
with a completely new idea and while I
assume
the general public would be open to and
amenable to the idea we really shouldn't
um
uh the idea is to pass the amendment and
then retain it so we'll we'll have
I guess maybe I didn't make myself clear
the point I was trying to make is that
you can't pass an amendment
like that without having the public
hearing on the amendment because it's a
completely different
it would turn the bill into a completely
different bill
so everybody who attended the original
public hearing on 213 would perceive to
be perceive it to be one thing but if we
changed it to something completely
different without a public hearing they
wouldn't know that so we would have to
have a public hearing
what about 315
excuse me
HP 315 wasn't changed completely it was
modified but it certainly wasn't changed
completely uh and the
we had two public hearings on hb315 so
nobody's going to be surprised with the
amended version of hp315 it's still
about Community aggregation and
Community power it's not about something
completely different it's not about a
study committee
yes thank you Mr chairman uh Mr chairman
wouldn't it be possible for us to
actually schedule a another hearing for
um
uh that would be March 12th Friday
that would still give us time before the
final date of March 18th that bills have
to be acted on by uh if we really wanted
to have this amendment or this study
committee replacing this bill we could
[Music]
our public hearing I believe you have to
get a week's notice
so earliest
notice it with the next week's calendar
March 19th
now the speaker did
under the authority ran into him by rule
six and seven
alter our deadlines author of the house
headlines
so it might be possible to help
carrying on March 19th but I'll have to
verify that with the clerk before
we commit to going forward what about
dot dot
press
the calendar of March 11th
would need to notice the meeting uh yeah
okay
thank you Mr chairman I just wanted to
mention I uh on hb213's combined
hearings we had one person in support of
HB 213 and we had 366 people who signed
in opposed
so we we would need to have legally and
technically we would need to have a
hearing uh if the if the bill were
substantly substantively going to change
but I guess my point would be that there
wasn't really anybody that we heard from
that was affected by that bill that was
in favor of it so we do know how the
public feels about the bill as it is
I think
we heard from a lot of different people
uh that were affected by it
sorry Mr chairman I I forgot to lower my
hand here representative oxenham
thank you I'd just like to Second your
suggestion that that you discussed this
with the clerk because I think with this
sort of four weeks out before we get to
the session we really do have an opening
here to make some changes to advance
okay thank you I will do that I will
check with the clerk and find out
when
we could hold a public hearing on that
Amendment
and if we have given the the seven day
notice period And if that would comply
with the
new deadlines that the speaker has
recently said I will look into that
either later today or first thing
tomorrow morning
thank you I noticed that no one has
their hand up so what I would like to do
right now uh if it's okay with everybody
is I would like to do
a straw poll
on your reaction to the new amendment to
house bill 315.
I'd like to get a sense of where the
committee would like to go with HP 315
it has broad bipartisan support from the
people who will actually Implement
Community aggregation and Community
power
and uh as a result of that I would hope
that this committee would support it as
well but the only way to find out for
sure is uh to do a straw poll so I'm
going to ask the clerk to call the roll
I'm going to ask you to respond with an
answer of yes or no about whether you
will support the amendment to House Bill
315 as presented this morning I will be
using the whole of the roster but I
won't be writing it
bit of sense yes we just want to get a
sense
responses just representative Paul is
President as always well before you do
that our representative oxenham had a
comment
just real quick that it the aggregator
Community is supporting it but also the
utilities are supporting that this is
It's broadly supported yes that's
correct that is correct
okay Mr Clark uh conduct a straw poll
representative Harry
representative
murder yes representative yes
representative yes
yes representative Cambridge yes
representative closure yes
representative white yes representative
keep going representative man yes
president Watson yes representative
yes Mr McGee yes representative Queens
she's going represent preaching
yes representative
yes the chair yes
um it's a company but it looks like you
have a shot at 21-0
I think we do I think we do and I thank
you very much everybody
in support of an extremely hard work to
make sure that after electricity
consumers are protected while uh the
opportunity for Innovation is also
encouraged and protected
look forward to that executive session
on Monday representative Mann is
recognized yes I had a question about
the wood industry is
um I don't know whether they're Fast
Response or not whether they fill in a
a hole in demand do they have to can
they come up quickly
representative
yes they can be on with it they have to
be on within 24 hours so the plan has to
be more like it's a low running
just daily running and they can fire it
up within 24 hours
[Music]
all right
that's been a lively discussion this
afternoon I see no more hens raised and
I'm going to Hazard a guess that we
might be able to call it a day a little
bit early yeah and get our weekend
started representative oxenham has other
ideas
I'm a little concerned I thought we were
going to talk about a couple of other
if you would like to like to do go right
ahead well but no honestly I I
understand that everybody feels like
they would like to get started on on
other things but I did think that we
might be able to get through a couple of
these really with um some alacrity and
the Broadband bill in particular was one
that I think our our we might actually
be unanimous again because this is
something that our constituents across
the board are concerned about whether
they're in urban areas or they're in
rural areas there's the intermittencies
they're the the drop there's not having
the speed there are many many issues
they're beyond our ability to talk about
in detail within the confines of our own
committee but establishing a group where
we would have experts and the companies
involved and constituents involved it
seems like something that we could just
say yes to and and it could go on the
consent calendar and we would be able to
get it started and off the ground
and and the final point about this is
that federal funds may be coming in and
if things are in progress they may
qualify for those funds but if we wait
for a year and deal with this in the
fall and vote on it in January we may
have missed the opportunity entirely
well you may be right about uh some of
those points but I'll remind you of what
we were told at the beginning of the
year
and that is if it's a study committee or
study commission bill and we pass it the
Senate will kill it
so we would we were advised to retain
all study committee bills and that's why
we
discussed after the public hearing
retaining that bill we didn't get around
to executing it apparently but we did
I'll double check if you would like with
the could you do that because things may
have changed since then yeah it was just
about to say
connect with the speaker to see if that
situation has changed and if it has then
maybe we can go forward with that bill
on Monday
um but I can't promise you that that
will be the case
representative appreciate
comment thank you
um yeah I just wanted to say that I I
spoke with a couple of the members of
the Senate um the other night we were at
a
remote event and they said that they had
passed a few study committee bills
through them so I don't know if there's
a difference between ones originating in
the Senate and ones originating in the
house but
um at least it sounded like they weren't
wholly opposed to every single study
committee so fingers crossed
okay I'll try to get clarification on
that
representative fimentel
yeah it's just a little bit of that
anecdotal I've been doing some Southern
this year I've subbed in three other
committees and all of them are passing
that's good feedback gives me some
ammunition to use with the speaker
um
representative Christian you still have
your hand up uh
okay all right
uh okay representative oxenham uh you
have the floor if you want to address
other bills now uh there's no other
oh could could we look in the
participants list and see if um
representative Weston is here to discuss
I'm having trouble bringing that up is
no I don't see her here if she's not on
the list of attendees
[Music]
um the the climate bill is one that it
kind of comes right out of our
presentation from Des
again we we had a major effort in 2009
2010 this uh I don't think we need that
now I think we understand the science so
much better we've had the admissions
commission which met from August to
December and came out with a
recommendation that there should be a
formal Commission on uh to take that
further uh what what this bill would do
is uh set some targets which are in line
with targets that we're seeing in the
surrounding states we were certainly
told by Des today that Regional
Solutions are the ones that have the
greatest impact who've seen the success
of the acid rain effort we've seen the
success of the Reggie effort
by having an opportunity to go forward
with this we would bring ourselves in
line with our our neighboring states the
um the goals are quite simple they're
available on in the middle of page two
lines 19 through 22 uh that shall be the
public policy of the State of New
Hampshire to reduce Statewide greenhouse
gas emissions
a is at least 20 below 1990 Levels by
2025 and I understand that we are on
target to meet debt at coming out of the
original climate action plan uh to have
at least 50 below 1990 Levels by 2035
and finally The Net Zero by 2050.
so having established those goals by
this legislation we would then hand off
to the bill says Des but since the
governor has now proclaimed that he's
going to establish a department of
energy it would be very useful to hand
the second part of this which is to draw
up the parameters of a plan that plan
would then come back to us we would
discuss it we would review it we would
change it if we felt necessary and then
put that into statute so that we would
have a Target going forward and that's
simply a Target but mechanisms uh that
would it says on page let's say three
lines nine through twenty just puts out
sort of a portfolio of things that might
be considered to be included within that
plan
um and again at the uh at the bottom of
page three it suggests that the
department would consult with the Public
Utilities Commission department of
transportation agriculture markets and
food at OSI will no longer exist
um throughout the plan development
process to ensure that these emissions
reductions are adopted and implemented
in ways that are complementary
non-duplicative and
in an efficient and cost effective
manner
so there's um some subsidiary reporting
but that's really that's really it
that's that's the nub of the bill we've
got Target goals and then we're asking a
department of the state government
which would undoubtedly be the
department of energy
to undertake a planning process and
bring that plan back to us I think it's
uh several years down the road on
not seeing the date right here in front
of me at the moment although it's
definitely here by July 1st 2023 the
department would bring back after public
comment the um
prepare an adopt a plan
and then review and update every five
years
so that's um the broad outlines of that
one
uh representative man you're recognized
yeah my um thank you Mr chairman my
constituents would be very happy with
that
I think we'd get a lot of positive uh
reaction from constituents across the
state but doing this
thank you
seeing none
I think it's time for us to start the
weekend
so let's uh let's get started on the
weekend we've got a full day of activity
planned for just two days from now back
here Monday morning at 10 o'clock to
start our uh exact session we'll see you
then I hope you have a wonderful weekend
same to you and I'm very happy with what
we did today and I think most of us are
dude some good stuff